prévient pas écouté mesdames messieurs
juste un petit mot d'introduction parce
que emmanuel m'a invité à le faire
on est très heureux avec les élus
sabolien de vous accueillir dans ce
cinéma confiance qui retrouve un peu d'
influence d'ailleurs ça fait du bien
même si on aurait aimé qu'ils aient plus
de monde en salle ce soir en tout cas on
est très heureux de bénéficier de cette
conférence avec monsieur jean qu ici on
a beaucoup de choses à apprendre
effectivement sur les enjeux de demain
mais qui sont des enjeux d'aujourd'hui
je pense surtout donc je vais laisser la
parole d'abord aimer l je crois est en
tout cas je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée à vous remercier encore de votre
présence ce soir ici dans cette salle à
merci merci monsieur le maire bercy
nicolas maintenir l'augmentation de la
température moyenne de la planète en
dessous de 2 degrés est un impératif
proclamé tel par la ratification de
l'accord de paris et qui nous sommes de
passer d'une logique d'intention et
d'ambition à une logique d'action et
d'exécution que ce soit en matière
d'urbanisme de biodiversité d'industrie
le champ couvert par la transition
écologique est large et appelle à une
modification de nos comportements de nos
objectifs et des politiques que nous
menons face aux conséquences directes de
nos modes de vie de nos habitudes de
consommation de notre rythme de
production actuel la question n'est plus
de savoir si nous devons agir mais bien
de définir comment nous allons agir
nous devons être à la hauteur des enjeux
éteindre la lumière en sortant d'une
pièce ou trier ses déchets ne suffiront
plus la réussite de la transition
écologique en sarthe sera donc
étroitement dépendante de la pertinence
de sa déclinaison dans nos territoires
mais aussi de l'appropriation de cet
enjeu de l'ensemble des publics et en
premier lieu par l'ensemble des élus et
agents territoriaux
c'est dans cette logique que le pays
vallée de la sarthe a élaboré son plan
climat en concertation avec les 62
communes et les trois communautés de
communes qui le composent
ce plan est en effet issu d'une démarche
qui implique l ensemble des parties
prenantes locales aussi bien citoyen qu
acteur associatif dirigeants
d'entreprise ou commerçants il s'est
traduit en objectifs concrets réduire
nos consommations énergétiques de 16%
d'ici à 2030 réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de plus de 15% tout
en augmentant nos capacités de stockage
de carbone de 18% d'ici 2031 multipliant
par 2,5
la production locale d'énergies
renouvelables nous n'allons pas nous
satisfaire d'action marginal de
compensation sans réduction ou
d'annoncés non suivies d'actions
ensemble nous allons repenser nos modes
de déplacements nos modes de chauffage
nos habitudes de consommation et de
travail et plus globalement notre
rapport à la nature
ensemble nous allons imaginer instaurer
ou adapter des solutions qui soient
cohérentes avec nos territoires ruraux
et avec nos spécificités locales
les collectivités territoriales ont des
leviers majeurs à leur disposition au
travers des domaines et des compétences
dont elles se saisissent organisation de
la voirie mobilité aménagement du
territoire construction gestion du
patrimoine bâti gestion des déchets
reconversion des emplois à nous
d'identifier les activités à risque
à nous de valoriser les formations de
nos équipes à nous d'assurer
l'information éclairé de nos concitoyens
tout cela sans oublier que la transition
a impulsé semaine également par des
actes individuels
de mon côté j'ai fait le calcul de mon
empreinte carbone 11 tonnes
je suis dans la moyenne française mais
pour donner je sais mais pas encore je
fais quand même attendre votre
conférence parce que le 6 mai pour
donner à chacun les moyens d'atteindre
l'ambition des deux tonnes prônée par
l'accord de paris nous allons devoir
proposer des alternatives sérieuses à
chacun de nos concitoyens sans laisser
de côté l'aspect social sans créer
d'exclusion de problèmes socio
économiques
sans oublier que la réussite de la
transition écologique est indissociable
de l'acceptabilité sociale le chemin
sera long et incertain mais le défi est
palpitant et pour nos enfants
il est vital littéralement
agissons donc toujours avec une ambition
renouvelée merci à notre invité
exceptionnel de jean marc jancovici de
nous faire l'honneur de sa présence à
sablé sur sarthe ce soir merci à toutes
et à tous d'être présent merci également
à celles et ceux qui nous suivent en
direct sur facebook et merci à l'équipe
technique d'avoir géré l'organisation de
cette soirée sous la houlette de ces
lignes elle la directrice du pays valida
sarthe
bonne soirée à tous
mais mes lunettes de mamie alors bonsoir
à tous comme aussi dit je vous remercie
d'être présent ce soir on aurait dû être
200 n'aurait largement rempli la salle
en effet on a voulu privilégier la
présence des élus ici ce soir du
territoire du syndicat pays vallée de la
sarthe mais on aurait aimé accueillir
plus de personnes en présentiel
d'autant que certains étaient prêts à
venir d'angoulême pour assister à cette
conférence
nous avons donc la chance d'accueillir
ce soir jean marc jancovici
pour ceux qui ne le connaissent pas jean
marc est ingénieur de l'école
polytechnique diplômé de l'école
nationale supérieure des
télécommunications il est le créateur du
bilan carbone qu'il a développée au sein
de l'ademe
il a co fondé en 2007 avec alain
grandjean carbone cap d'un cabinet de
conseil qui réalise des bilans carbone
pour les entreprises
j'ai copié collé wikipédia je me suis
pas cassé la tête ainsi que
l'association the shift project en 2010
qui est un laboratoire d'idées qui s'est
donné pour objectif l'atténuation du
changement climatique et la réduction de
la dépendance de l'économie aux énergies
fossiles
il est également membre du haut conseil
pour le climat et je vous passe ses
autres activités dont la liste est
longue comme le bras
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer
jean-marc l'année dernière c'était même
ya plus il ya plus de ça c'est au mois
d'octobre 2010 9 dans le cadre de la
convention citoyenne du pour le climat
jean marc était venu faire une
intervention de 5-6 minutes c'était pas
beaucoup d'ailleurs s'était passé mais
bref prendre a bu un coup ensemble on a
fait connaissance et ensuite j'ai voulu
participer à un atelier du shift project
le shift fait des ateliers je crois que
c'est tous les mois
alors depuis le coc vite c'est en
visioconférence mais ces pratiques aussi
parce que les ateliers sont à paris et
je ne fais pas paris tous les mois voilà
les et que je me suis inscrite les
équipes du shift ont vu que je faisais
partie de la convention et du coup ils
m'ont repéré ils m'ont dit est ce qu est
papa
participer à une table ronde avec
jean-marc bon d'accord et s'en est suivi
une série d'interventions donc d'abord
en présentiel ensuite en en
visioconférence et depuis on a gardé le
lien
voilà comment aujourd'hui l'illustrent
jean marc jancovici est aujourd'hui à
sablé il nous fait le plaisir et
l'honneur d'être là parce que bon c'est
pas non plus une contrée qui visitent
souvent comme tu nous disais tout à
l'heure tu passes mais tu t'arrêtes toi
voilà c'est tout moi je passe la parole
à à céline pour le côté technique de la
soirée merci à tous merci bonsoir à
toutes et à tous bienvenue donc je
m'appelle céline belge de la directrice
du pays vallée de la sarthe donc au vu
du contexte sanitaire évidemment où vous
demande de garder vos masques pendant la
durée de toute la conférence est de
respecter les gestes barrière ça fait un
peu hôtesse de l'air comme je dis ça
mais vraiment c'est important donc la
jauge est limitée ce soir à 35% de la
capacité de la salle mais en même temps
que la conférence on organise une
captation vidéo et une retransmission en
direct sur notre page facebook
voilà comme ça ça permet à plus de monde
de nous suivre et j'en profite pour
remercier toute l'équipe technique
dave gbl audiovisuels sans qui tout ça
n'aurait pas été possible
pendant la conférence nous aurons aussi
une traduction illustrer des propos de
monsieur jancovici et là j'en profite
pour remercier cécile molines qui est
notre facilitatrice graphique et qui
nous suivra toute la soirée
enfin à la fin de la présentation on
aura un temps des changes et de débats
alors pour poser vos questions on vous
invite à nous envoyer des sms au numéro
de téléphone qui va peut-être sa fiche
et dernière - ou pas donc je vais vous
le donner parce que je laisse sur ma
note
donc c'est au 06 78 15 14 63 voilà ça
nous évitera en fait de faire circuler
le micro et ça permettra à celles et
ceux qui sont visio de sentir aussi à
l'aise
que nous présents dans la salle pour
poser leurs questions
voilà et enfin un dernier mot pour
remercier l'équipe du cinéma confluence
hélène et anaïs de nous accueillir ce
soir
et puis aussi toutes les petites mains
du pays qui ont contribué à
l'organisation de la soirée donc carole
isabelle laurine julie et olivier et
marguerite qui est pas tout à fait de
l'équipe mais qu'elle a quand même
voilà je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée et je vous demande d'accueillir
comme il se doit
jean marc jancovici moi j'ai droit un
micro désinfecter c'est parfait du coup
j'ai droit de l'infecté alors avant de
commencer cette intervention
maintenant que vous savez tout sur le
marié carbonique mans au premier regard
entre mélanie et moi comme c'est elle
qui m'a invité gmi souvigné je vois là
je suis désolé les autres n'existent pas
c'est comme ça la deuxième chose
avant de avant de démarrer c'est que
j'espère que le titre un tout petit peu
violent ne va pas vous rebuter mais en
fait j'aurais aussi pu intituler cette
intervention deux siècles d'histoire
vous verrez qu'en fait c'est à peu près
la même chose
et j'aurais également pu l'intituler le
drame de l'élu parce que vous allez
comprendre la fin de l'intervention que
c'est justement de ça entre autres dont
il est question
alors mais comme j'ai marqué physique je
vais aller jusqu'au bout du vous savez
il faut boire le calice jusqu'à la lie
alors je vais aller jusqu'au bout de la
lie et je vais commencer avec une
horrible équation alors c'est pas une
horrible équation en fait c'est un truc
assez simple ce que je vais essayer de
vous expliquer pendant les quelques
quart d'heure pendant lesquels je vais
causer tout seul comme un grand avant
les questions c'est que quand on regarde
l'histoire des deux derniers siècles
en fait on peut assez facilement montrer
qu' il ya eu autant d'économies qu'il ya
eu des énergies et il ya eu autant de
co2 c'est à dire de futurs changements
climatiques qui a eu d'énergie donc en
gros si vous regardez les deux derniers
siècles
vous vous rendez compte qu'il ya trois
choses qui ont évolué de concert c'est
l'éclat taille de l'économie
la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise et
les émissions de co2 tout ça est allé à
peu près à la même vitesse et on va
essayer de comprendre pourquoi alors la
première chose que je vais faire c'est
de vous montrer qu'effectivement je vous
raconte pas de carabistouilles quand je
vous dis que l'économie et l'énergie
sont allés à peu près la même vitesse
alors voici une petite courbe que je
j'ai commencé à faire pour voir la tête
que ça avait il ya une dizaine d'années
puis quand enfin oui une quinzaine
d'années maintenant depuis le temps que
des dix ans et quand j'ai vu la tête que
ça avait je me suis dit tiens il ya
c'est vraiment très étonnant je vais
essayer de comprendre pourquoi lorsque
ce que cette courbe elle est très simple
vous avez sur ce graphique en abscisse
donc sur l'axé horizontal la quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise dans le monde
peu importe unités et puis vous avez en
ordonner ce qu'on a coutume d'utiliser
pour quantifier la taille de l'économie
c'est-à-dire le pib ou savez le fameux
pib celui qui quand ils montent tout va
bien quand il descend tout va mal et qui
en fait quand il fit la taille de
l'économie
pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont pas très
familier de cette notion le pib c'est
juste la valeur totale de tout ce qu'on
a produit dans l'année voilà c'est ça le
c'est ça le pib est bien vous voyez que
la valeur totale de ce qu'on produit
dans l'année évolué de manière
parfaitement linéaire en fonction de la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise donc en
gros plus à d'énergie plus être pib plus
être pib plus il ya d'énergie ça vous
dit toujours pas où la poule et wolof
mais ce que vous voyez c'est
qu'effectivement le premier terme de mon
égalité à respecter plus à d'énergie et
ses linéaires mais ça augmente
exactement de la même manière
voilà la deuxième courbe qui va avec la
deuxième partie de mon égalité alors je
recommence même motif même punition en
bas là cette fois ci vous avez la
quantité totale d'énergie qu'on utilise
dans le monde et sur l'axé vertical vous
avez la quantité totale de co2 qu'on
crache dans l'atmosphère à cause de
l'utilisation de l'énergie et par vous
voyez qu'on a affaire à une droite à
nouveau par fait donc plus à d'énergie
puis à de co2 puis à de co2 puis à
d'énergie si vous essayez de trouver
dans cette courbe l'arrivée du nucléaire
ou des énergies renouvelables vous le
voyez pas vous voyez pas mais ça reste
parfaitement rectiligne en bas à gauche
là vous êtes en 1965 en haut à droite
vous êtes en 2019
voilà autant d'énergie cas de co2 autant
d'énergie quatre auteurs de co2 qui a
des énergies alors maintenant que je
vous ai montré que les trois termes de
cette égalité se valaient vraiment
encore une fois on va essayer de
comprendre pourquoi et pour comprendre
pourquoi on va ramener à la vie active
un retraité il n'y a pas de raison qu'il
n'a pas l'âge et on va essayer de
commencer à répondre à la question qui
est qu'est-ce que l'énergie a observé
que dans ce pays un ministre de
l'énergie vous êtes au courant qu'un
ministre de l'énergie et bien je vous
fiche mon billet que si on lui pose la
question de savoir ce que c'est que
l'énergie vous allez obtenir tout sauf
la bonne réponse vous allez voir
pourquoi alors un premier réflexe très
pavlovien qui nous vient à l'esprit
quand on nous dit énergie c'est c'est ça
et du reste on l'a très bien vu à cette
époque-là très bien vu l'énergie c'est
une facture c'est pas un sujet est du
reste très souvent quand vous avez des
débats sur l'énergie c'est des débats
sur la facture d'électricité combien ça
va coûter les débats sur la facture des
gascons mais ça va coûter
alors malheureusement ce que je vais
essayer de vous montrer c'est que c'est
pas la bonne question parce que quand on
regarde ce que nous coûte l'énergie au
regard des services que ça nous rend en
fait la seule bonne réponse sur le coût
de l'énergie c'est gratuit à peu près
bonne réponse sur le coût de l'énergie
alors en fait c'est pas tout à fait
gratuit mais pas loin
si je regarde ce que coûte aux hommes et
aux femmes dans le monde
globalement l'énergie que nous utilisons
donc le pétrole le charbon le gaz
l'électricité vous allez voir qu'en fait
c'est très souvent du charbon et du gaz
eh bien ça représente quelques pourcents
de ce qu'on gagne quelques pour cent du
pib dont quelques pourcents de ce qu'on
gagne chaque année donc le coût total le
fait d'acheter du pétrole du gaz et du
charbon dans le monde
ça coûte quelques pourcents de ce qu'on
gagne et alors à ce moment ci c'est
comme ça qu'on prend le problème c'est à
dire sous l'angle de combien ça coûte
et bien ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
y passer quelques pour cent du temps au
mieux parce qu'un problème qui coûte
quelques pourcents de ce qu'on gagne on
va pas y passer la nuit
c'est quand même plus important de
s'occuper de son loyer et quand on
dirige une entreprise c'est plus un coût
plus important de s'occuper des salaires
et les charges
alors malheureusement ce que ce
raisonnement ne vous dit pas c'est
combien tout le reste en dépend parce
que vous voyez votre cervelle ces 2 %
votre poids c'est juste 2 % de votre
poids donc je pourrais vous dire bah
c'est pas grave si vous la perdez vous
allez perdre 2 % d'efficacité pas très
grave non en fait vous comprenez bien
que ce raisonnement est totalement idiot
parce que ça a beau être deux pour cent
de votre point tout le reste de votre
corps en dépend classy je vous enlève
votre cervelle plus rien plus rien du
reste de fonctionne et comme je vois que
cette salle est à dominante masculine
je vais vous donner un autre exemple le
poids de la testostérone dans les
organismes masculin que j'ai en face de
moi c'est beaucoup moins une pour cent
de votre point je peux vous assurer que
si je voulais enlève votre corps ne
ressemble plus à ce qu'il est donc la
question de la part de camembert dans
les dépenses en fait masque une
information essentielle c'est combien
tout le reste de ce qu'on fait des pans
de cette part là alors je vais vous
donner un exemple idiot avec un engin de
transport que je viens d'utiliser
aujourd'hui s'appelle un train au sein
de la sncf
orco vide l'énergie ça leur coûte à peu
près 3% de leur chiffre d'affaires il
faut savoir que la sncf est le premier
consommateur d'électricité du pays
la sncf orco vide consomme 1 25% de la
production électrique du pays
et c'est également à des premiers
consommateurs d'hydrocarbures puisque
beaucoup de ter fonctionne au diesel
dont vous avez également un gros poste
achats d'hydrocarbures
a la sncf et bien tout ça rate ou
mouillé c'est 3% de leur charge sauf que
si vous leur enlevez vous avez plus un
train qui avancent donc on comprend bien
que c'est 3 % des charges mais tout le
reste en dépend c'est pas 3% équivalent
à autre chose
par exemple à des salaires de cheminots
parce que si vous enlevez 3 % de charge
sous forme de salaire de cheminots la
sncf la sncf pardon se met en grève mais
enfin derrière il y aura quand même des
trains qui finiront par roulait donc
l'énergie encore une fois si on regarde
ce que ça vaut dans ce qu'on dépense en
fait on rate un point essentiel c'est
combien tout le reste de ce qu'on fait
des pans de cette part là alors après il
ya une deuxième réponse la connaissez
l'énergie deuxième réflexe pavlovien
c'est faut l'économiser est du reste
vous connaissez tous cette petite maxime
que je pourrais vous faire répéter tous
en choeur tous en choeur tous en choeur
la meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas du reste si vous demandez
un moteur de recherche dont je ne
nommerai pas le nom si vous tapez le
début la meilleure énergie vous regardez
ce qui arrive derrière c'est celle qu'on
consomme pas et c'est alors ou bien on
est sourd ou bien nous sommes
particulièrement bête parce que ça fait
un siècle et demi que la meilleure
énergie est celle qu'on consomme de plus
en plus donc il ya probablement des gens
qui ont pas bien écouté en cours dans
cette histoire parce que si c'est celle
qu'on ne consomme pas c'est pas du tout
ça qu on devrait observer ici vous avez
la quantité totale d'énergie qu'on
utilise sur terre depuis un siècle et
demi lorsque vous pouvez voir c'est que
historiquement tout en bas l'envers on a
commencé par utiliser du bois qu'on a
aussi utilisé je viendrai dans pas
longtemps
les autres énergies renouvelables et
puis par dessus le bois on s'est mis à
utiliser du charbon mais par dessus
vous voyez que ça remplace pas après par
dessus on s'est mis à utiliser du
pétrole mais ça remplace pas le charbon
par dessus le pétrole on s'est mis à
utiliser du gaz
ça remplace rien de ce qu'ils avaient
avant par dessus l'hydroélectricité part
du nucléaire mais alors tout temps ou en
rose là ce que vous voyez c'est les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables donc
c'est le machin dont on tartine les
journaux à longueur de journée et
regardez ce que ça représente
aujourd'hui comme par dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
vous voyez que pour le moment c'est
quelque chose qui a une importance qui
n'est pas du tout en rapport avec la
pagination que ça peut occuper dans le
journal maintenant vous êtes tous bien
placé puisque un certain nombre d'entre
vous dans cette salle sont élus
pour savoir qu en première approximation
n'y a pas le moindre rapport entre
l'importance réelle de quelque chose et
la place que ça occupe dans le journal
et c'est pas vrai juste pour l'énergie
c'est vrai d'une manière générale eh ben
c'est aussi vrai pour l'énergie
ce que vous voyez également sur cette
courbe c'est que il ya un certain nombre
d'évolutions alors en fait sur cette
cour on peut placer plein de trucs dont
on dit aujourd'hui à mais si on fait ça
ça va permettre d'utiliser moins
d'énergie parce que c'est plus efficace
alors je vous en livre quelques uns
pêle-mêle mais j'aurais pu en prendre
d'autres
on a souvent entendu c'est plus efficace
de rassembler les gens dans les villes
parce que comme ça c'est plus compact et
alors les gens du coup se déplacent
moins et c est bien vous voyez l'essor
des villes le boom des villes dans le
monde
ça commence aprés guerre et vous voyez
l'évolution de la consommation d'énergie
derrière manifestement ça n'a pas été si
efficace que ça autre chose
l'économie se tertiarisée il ya plus en
plus de services en ciel plus en plus de
services et de moins en moins
consommateurs d'énergie etc
regardez l'évolution derrière ça doit se
discuter que ça a permis d' et enfin un
dernier truc c'est la digitalisation ans
la digitalisation c'est plus efficace ça
évite de se déplacer etc
regardez comment évolue la consommation
d'énergie après qu'on ait commencé à
avoir des ordinateurs manifestement ça
marche pas si facilement que ça et là
dessus j'aurais pu vous mettre n'importe
quoi d'autre un la conquête de la lune
l'invention de la voiture là ancion
d'être un flop mais tout ce que vous
voulez vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas la moindre inventions techniques
dont on dit aujourd'hui que elle va
permettre de régler le problème de la
consommation croissante d'énergie qui
historiquement a joué ce rôle
pas une fois c'est arrivé et enfin le
point important c'est que vous notez que
l'essentiel de l'énergie qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui sur terre est ce qu'on
appelle de l'énergie fossile
alors le dictionnaire est bien fait ça
s'appelle énergies fossiles parce que
c'est des faux cils le charbon c'est des
fossiles de fougères qui ont poussé à
l'ère du charbon le carbonifère il ya
300 millions d'années alors ça a été
très très lentement cuit beaucoup plus
lentement que la quiche aux oignons dont
je parlais tout à l'heure
très très lentement cuit pendant des
centaines de millions d'années sous
terre le chalet fougères des temps
anciens se sont enfouis par la
tectonique des plaques sous terre et
puis ça a été très très lentement
chauffé par la chaleur géothermique et
ça finit par donner du charbon
et le pétrole et le gaz c'est exactement
pareil sauf qu'au lieu de 30 des
fougères au début vous prenez du
plancton et des petites salles qui ont
vécu dans l'océan et au même motif même
punition une partie tombe sur le
plancher océanique s'est enfoui par la
tectonique des plaques
ça cuit beaucoup plus longtemps qu une
daube quelques dizaines de millions
d'années au moins
et à l'arrivée vous avez du pétrole et
du gaz donc c'est pour ça qu'on les
appelle des énergies fossiles sais
vraiment pas ce que c'est des fossiles
je fais une toute petite parenthèse on
appelle parfois l'uranium énergies
fossiles c'est faux c'est un métal
c'est en quantité philippe c'est pas
faux cils c'est pas un reste de vie
ancienne
ce que vous voyez donc sur ce graphique
c'est que l'essentiel de l'énergie qu'on
utilise sur terre aujourd'hui c'est des
combustibles fossiles et c'est vrai
également si vous regardez un vecteur
que nous utilisons tous les jours
le vecteur magique de christian clavier
vous savez jour nuit qui s'appelle
l'électricité vous avez ici la manière
dont on produit l'électricité sur terre
depuis 1985 alors le en 1985 on est donc
tout à tout à gauche sur ce graphique
j'arrive pas manipulation mais attend
pas de souris si voilà vous voyez ici on
est en 1985 et l'humanité produit dix
mille milliards de kilowattheure
électrique
dix mille milliards mille milliards on
appelle ça un térawattheures dans le
dans le
un milliard de kilowattheures ça
s'appelle la terre à water donc timide
et puis voyez ça augmente ça augmente ça
augmente ça augmente aujourd'hui on est
passé au dessus de 25 mille milliards de
kilowattheure électrique produit alors
dans cette histoire qu'est ce qui a
augmenté le charbon a augmenté et vous
voyez que en fait en valeur absolue sur
la période ses deux très loin le mode de
production électrique qui a le plus
augmenté
et même si je regarde les vingt
dernières années de très loin ce qui a
le plus augmenté sur terre c'est la
production électrique au charbon alors
comment est ce qu'on fait de
l'électricité avec du charbon c'est
assez simple avec le charbon vous faites
de la chaleur avec la chaleur on fait
bouillir de l'eau ça vous créer de la
vapeur et avec la vapeur ou fait tourner
une turbine
c'est exactement le même principe dans
une centrale à gaz c'est exactement le
même principe dans une centrale à
pétrole et c'est exactement le même
principe dans une centrale nucléaire à
chaque fois vous faites de la chaleur
c'est juste la bannière de faire la
chaleur qui n'est pas la même
puis vous faites de la vapeur puis vous
faites tourner une turbine donc vous et
que le charbon a beaucoup augmenté
le gaz a considérablement augmenté au
cir le gaz c'est une énergie fossile
aussi il reste un peu de pétrole là vous
voyez nucléaire la l'hydroélectricité et
là les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que dans
la production électrique dans le monde
les deux modes décarbonés qui domine
c'est l'hydroélectricité et le nucléaire
arrive ensuite l'éolien le biogaz et le
solaire qui sont à peu près à parité
donc le solaire c'est le petit machin
orange que vous avez là donc l'essentiel
de l'électricité sur terre aujourd'hui
les deux tiers pour être précis c'est
des énergies fossiles donc l'électricité
c'est pas du tout un vecteur décarbonés
suffit pas de dire je fais de
l'électricité et parce que là où je m'en
sers il n'y a pas de fumée et ça pue pas
du coup c'est propre
il faut aussi regarder ce qui se passe
là on la produit et en fait
l'électricité est aussi propre aussi
sale que la manière de la produire
d'accord elle a les mêmes inconvénients
que la façon de la produire
alors la france est très atypique par
rapport au monde dans son ensemble parce
que vous avez ici le même graphique pour
la france
lorsque vous voyez pour la france c'est
que le petit la petite bande jaune là
que vous aviez ici laquelle nucléaire
c'est devenu un gros gros paquet jaune
en france donc en france l'essentiel de
notre électricité est produit avec du
nucléaire que vous voyez ici en jaune
il ya une quantité hydroélectrique qui
est à peu près constante sur la période
parce que les grands barrages ont été
faits dans les années 70
70 pardon je trouve que les belges sont
plus logique que nous sur la
numérotation et depuis on n'en fait plus
et la micro hydraulique pour ceux
d'entre vous qui en ont entendu parler
dans le dictionnaire à nouveau bien fait
ces micro donc ça fait des toutes
petites quantités d'électricité les
grandes quantités d'électricité sont
faits par les grands barrages que vous
allez trouver dans les massifs
montagneux est ce que vous voyez c'est
que depuis 2005
en fait on a un peu baissé le nucléaire
un peu augmenter la quantité
d'électricité fait autrement qu'avec le
nucléaire
par contre la quantité d'électricité
qu'on fait avec des combustibles
fossiles sur la période a pas énormément
varié alors elle descend un peu elle
monte un peu et en fait c'est bien là
qu'est le problème en ce qui concerne le
climat
il est pas là il est pas là et il n'est
pas là encore que dans le solaire il ya
quand même 50 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure donc le ce qu'il faut
faire donc le la partie fossiles dans la
production électrique française et c'est
celle là qui est l'objet de nos
attentions si on s'occupe du climat
voyez ce qu'elles représentent elles
représentent la partie du bas
l'essentiel de la production électrique
française donc à linverse de la
production électrique mondiale elle elle
est déjà décarbonée elle est décarbonée
depuis la mise en route du programme
nucléaire qui a pas du tout été fait
pour ça il n'a pas du tout été fait pour
protéger le filet mais il se trouve que
c'est un avantage acquis que nous avons
avec donc j'en reviens à mon pré
retraités une facture c'est pas vraiment
la bonne manière de voir les choses
l'économiser sais pas du tout ce qu'on a
fait alors maintenant tout le monde va
être renouvelable
alors j'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour
vous ça ne pose aucun problème c'est si
ça ne pose aucun problème
regardez voilà à monde 100 %
renouvelable ça ne pose aucun problème
du rsa posent tellement aucun problème
que le monde dans lequel les hommes et
les femmes ont vécu depuis leur
apparition il ya vingt mille ans pour
sapiens sapiens jusqu'à ya deux siècles
a été en permanence un monde 100 %
renouvelable en permanence donc des
points d'échantillonnage pour un monde
100 % renouvelable je vous en donne
autant vous voulez autant vous voulez
faire un monde 100 % renouvelable ne
pose aucun problème aucun
mais on n'a pas dû trouver ça si génial
que ça puisque ça fait deux siècles
qu'on passe notre temps à sortir des
énergies renouvelables oui on avait une
marines renouvelables
voilà un bateau renouvelables en bois
renouvelables avec des voiles en lin ou
en coton renouvelables des marins
renouvelables renouveler quand ils
m'auraient du scorbut et naviguant
paisiblement sur la mer renouvelables
bon et puis on a dit c'est pas terrible
c'est quand même vachement mieux d'avoir
ce genre de trucs voilà un transport
terrestre parfaitement renouvelables
avec un cheval renouvelables et qui est
du reste été renouvelé dans nos estomacs
il ya des boucheries chevalines mangeant
de l'erdre renouvelables tirant une
charrette en bois renouvelable tout ça
est parfaitement renouvela puis on a dit
c'est pas terrible quand même il vaut
beaucoup mieux à voir ça ça a l'air de
bien marcher
nous avions des tracteurs renouvelables
en voici un
voilà il était comestible à la
différence des tracteurs haendel
actuelle un peu moins mangeant de
l'herbe renouvelables etc puis au plus
tôt à 10 ans c'est pas terrible encore à
faire ça on avait des travaux publics
renouvelables donc on faisait la via
appia les voies romaines et c'est à la
mano avec des gens qui mangeaient de
l'herbe renault fois de l'ère blanc et
mangé un peu mieux que ça souvent même
les esclaves puis on a dit non c'est
quand même vachement mieux de faire ça
ça permet de faire les lotissements
beaucoup plus vite n'est ce pas faire
les lotissements beaucoup plus vite on
avait une industrie de la construction
parfaitement renouvelables avec des
ouvriers renouvelables qui mangeaient là
aussi de la nourriture renouvelables de
siècle pour faire notre dame en première
version en deuxième macron a dit que ça
irait plus vite et on s'est dit quand
même pour faire des grands cornichons à
la défense ça va beaucoup plus vite
d'avoir une construction fossiles et
donc on est passé aux fossiles on avait
une industrie c'est pas 2 c'est pas une
deuxième manière de fayots tech mélanie
on avait une industrie parfaitement
renouvelables avec ici vous avez une
route moulin en bois renouvelables
tournant avec de l'eau renouvelables etc
puis on s'est dit non quand même pour
alimenter toys'r'us ça marche mieux ça
donc on va faire ça on a même des
séchoirs à l'usaid renouvelables
s'appelle le soleil aujourd'hui nous
avons des séchoirs luz est un gaz
beaucoup plus efficace
et enfin nous avions une aviation
renouvelables vous voyez ici le premier
aéronef des frères montgolfier avec du
papier papier c'est du bois parfaitement
renouvelables sur un montant grâce à la
chaleur d'un feu de bois parfaitement
renouvelables puis on s'est dit non
quand même ça c'est plus efficace
donc ça fait deux siècles en fait on
passe notre temps à sortir des énergies
renouvelables pareil à les en sortir
alors je repose la question où on est
des crétins patentés ou bien il ya une
raison physique pour laquelle on a fait
ça est alors la mauvaise très mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qu'en fait il ya des
raisons physiques
imaginons que l'on prenne le volume de
cette salle dans laquelle je suis soit
dit en passant très heureux d'être parce
que depuis le coc vite c'est la première
fois que je me retrouve dans une salle
donc ça faisait un an que j'avais même
pas mon mode présentateur parce que
quand on fait des visions l'apa et donc
j'étais très très malheureux donc
imaginons qu'on prenne le volume d'air
de cette salle en première approximation
je veux dire que c'est un cube de 10
mètres sur 10 mètres alors en fait à peu
près ça le volume des russes et ça je le
fais soufflé à 80 km/heure donc vous
n'êtes pas dans le pays dans des pays du
sud
c'est pas du toit reproche donc le
mistral et la tramontane s'est pas trop
votre truc vous avez 80 km heure ça
commence à être avant sympathique quoi
et vous le faites pas c'est dans une
éolienne
vous allez donc récupérer l'énergie de
les mettre l'éolienne en mouvement à
récupérer de l'énergie et bien mille
mètres cubes d'air en mouvement passant
dans une éolienne ça vous fournit la
même quantité d'énergie que ce que vous
avez dans 3000 litres de pétrole bien vu
alors je vous pose la question à votre
avis qu'est-ce qui est le plus simple
d'avoir trois mille litres de pétrole ou
d'avoir une éolienne de 150 mètres de
haut et 10 faire souffler mille mètres
cube d'air à votre avis
sans compter qu'avec mon éolienne votre
voiture avance si elle avance à
l'électricité quand il ya du vent enfin
non une batterie ce mauvais exemple
enfin pour comprendre l'énergie est
disposée côté du vent alors qu'avec le
pétrole votre stock il est déjà là votre
pétrole il est disponible qui est du
vent pas de banquier du soleil pas de
soleil qui fasse chaud qu'il fasse froid
en plus disponibles et en fait la raison
pour laquelle on est passé du vent au
pétrole
elle est là c'est à cause des
caractéristiques physiques intrinsèque
de chaque forme d'énergie et qui fait
que les énergies fossiles s'est
considérablement plus dense beaucoup
plus facile à transporter a utilisé
indépendamment des conditions locales et
donc ça a permis de mettre en route tout
un tas de machines qu'on n'aurait jamais
pu mettre en route avec juste les
énergies renouvelables c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait cette transition des
énergies renouvelables vers les énergies
fossiles
à l'époque on sait pas dit ça va
emmerder nos descendants faire du
changement climatique puis un jour il y
en aura plus je sais les gens moi inclus
un siècle c'est moins donc on l'a fait
puis on l'a fait mais à cause de ça et
alors quand on regarde aujourd'hui la
traduction économique de 7 différences
de caractéristiques physiques
quand vous avez un kilowattheure éoliens
en france dont j'ai pris en france ça se
baladent quelque part entre 4 et 8
centimes alors l'off shore va vous en
coûter 15 les très bon gisement à terre
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être quatre
vingts peu importe on est dans ces
eaux-là 1 6 6 6 8 centimes un peu plus
un peu moins aimé ça c'est vous fait
opérer du genou s'il ya du vent ou la
classe démarre à 8 heures s'il ya du
vent si vous voulez que la classe
démarre à 8 heures même si a pas de vent
fort a ajouté du stockage d'accord a
ajouté huit otages et donc à ce moment
le coût du stockage ont multiplié par
trois en gros tout compris
donc on se balade avec un kilowattheure
éolien avec quelque chose qui va vous
coûter plusieurs dizaines de centimes au
moins 20 à 30 de l'autre côté
votre kilowattheure de pétrole je dis
bien votre kilowattheure de pétrole
sortie du désert saoudien déjà stocké
donc déjà vous en servez comme vous
voulez il vous coûte une fraction de
centimes
donc vous avez un facteur de différence
de quelques dizaines entre l'éolien et
le pétrole et ça reflète les
caractéristiques physiques intrinsèque
de chacune des énergies et encore ce
facteur devrait être beaucoup plus
important pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui
votre éolienne moderne
elle est fabriquée avec des combustibles
fossiles elle est fabriquée avec du
charbon pour faire la métallurgie pour
faire l'acier elle est fabriquée avec du
pétrole pour transporter et ériger tous
les composants et puis par ailleurs pour
faire les pales en fibre de verre etc
enfin en fibre de carbone et avec du gaz
pour faire le ciment qui va servir à
faire le plot de béton
si demain matin vous avez plus tout ça
parce qu'on est dans un monde 100 %
renouvelable
est-ce que vous pensez que le prix de
votre éolienne va rester le même
c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr comme je dis
parfois je suis pas sûr que je parierais
toutes mes économies là dessus non en
fait non c'est absolument certain qu'il
ne restera pas là donc en fait
aujourd'hui le coût des énergies
renouvelables n'est pas élevé parce que
nous avons toujours un système facile
mais si on veut se débarrasser du
système fossiles
et en fait le seul à être ça le drame
que je vais sur lequel je vais continuer
d'élaborer ce soir je pense qu'il ya un
certain nombre de gens j'en suis même
sûr il ya deux siècles ya trois siècles
à quatre siècles ya cinq siècles il ya
six siècles qui était beaucoup plus
intelligents que nous tous réunis dans
cette salle je pense que mozart qui a
composé des symphonies à 84 ans ou 5 ans
était juste un génie absolu
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'il ait des
équivalents depuis je pense que léonard
de vinci et archimède était aussi des
génie absolu et c'est donc si ces gens
là qui était aussi intelligents que nous
n'ont pas réussi à faire émerger une
civilisation industrielle à l'époque des
énergies renouvelables peut-être que la
raison c'est que juste il pouvait pas
parce que les énergies renouvelables
n'ont pas les caractéristiques physiques
intrinsèque qui permettent de faire
vivre 8 milliards de terriens comme un
smicard français et peut-être juste ça
le sujet est en fait c est là que je
voulais vous amener donc là vous avez
trois réponses qui moi ne me satisfont
pas au sens de c'est pas le réflexe
pavlovien qu'il faut avoir quand on
pense énergie en fait le réflexe
pense énergie c'est iron man voilà c'est
ça le réflexe pavlovien qu'il faut que
vous ayez l'énergie c'est iron man les
idées bloquent complètement et trop bu
de vin à l'apéro non je n'ai pas du tout
non pas du tout effectivement l'énergie
c'est iron man ou plus exactement
l'énergie c'est la bibine d'iron man
c'est ça l'énergie c'est la bibine
d'iron man alors c'est quoi iron man des
temps modernes
évidemment vous n'avez pas chez vous
l'armure d'iron man version rouge pour
les hommes version pardon rouge pour les
filles bleu pour les hommes non c'est
pas ça que vous avez chez vous mais vous
l'avez quand même voilà à quoi il
ressemble l'armure d'iron man et celle
là vous l'avez vraiment chez vous le
petit doigt gauche d'iron man
c'est le tractopelle que vous avez là la
main droite d'iron man c'est le train
que vous avez là la bouche d'iron man
c'est la machine de filtration que vous
avez là la mâchoire d'iron man c'est la
presse à emboutir que vous avez là et
c'est en fait à l'ironman
il est vraiment parmi nous sauf qu'il
est parmi nous en pièces détachées en
petits morceaux et c'est l'ensemble de
la machinerie mondiale qui s'est mise à
travailler pour nous
les vêtements que vous portez puisqu'il
est interdit de venir tout nu dans cette
salle ont été fabriqués par
machine ils ont été transportés par des
machines vous les avez achetés dans des
magasins qui ont été construits par des
machines ou si vous les avez achetés en
ligne
vous les avez achetés avec une machine
qui est un ordinateur ils sont passés
par un entrepôt construit par des
machines acheminés chez vous par des
camions qui sont des machines ce que
vous avez mangé au petit déjeuner a été
cultivée par des machines des tracteurs
et de moissonneuses batteuses transforme
et réfrigérer transportés par des
machines
cui éventuellement par des machines nous
vivons dans un monde de machines et ceux
qui bossent ces machines c'est pas des
hommes et des femmes qui ont fabriqué
les fauteuils sur lesquels vous êtes
assis c'est les machines c'est pas qui
est venu à pied ici ce soir
bah voilà tous les autres sont des
machines 60 chevaux attelés dans le
carrosse instantanément donc nous vivons
ça c'est pour les petites voitures
nous vivons donc dans un monde de
machines c'est ça et donc l'énergie
c'est la nourriture de ces machines
donc en fait plus on a des énergies plus
on consomme d'énergie en fait ça veut
dire plus on utilise de machines c'est
ça qu'il faut comprendre parce que c'est
pas vous qui buvaient le pétrole enfin
tout cas je vous le déconseille c'est
pas terrible
si vous essayez de vous mettre le truc
de la pompe à essence dans la bouche là
vous ferez l'expérience un jour je pense
que vous avez trouvé ça moins bon qu'un
petit vin donc même pas terrible donc le
l'énergie c'est de la nourriture pour
machines est en fait dire qu'on utilise
de plus en plus d'énergie en fait ça
peut juste dire qu'on utilise de plus en
plus de machines qu'on a une capacité à
maîtriser notre environnement et à le
transformer qui augmente c'est ça que ça
veut dire c'est juste ça que ça veut
dire
alors on va prendre des quelques
exemples de machines pour que vous
compreniez un peu de quoi on parle
maintenant
d'abord la première machine que je vais
prendre c'est vous nous sommes surtout
les hommes des machines c'est à dire que
nous sommes des convertisseurs d'énergie
on mange beaucoup trop parfois en bois
brut rossi et derrière on va en faire de
la chaleur beaucoup parce qu'on est des
animaux à sang chaud faut qu'on se
maintienne à 37 degrés et du mouvement
un peu
sauf quand on est avachi devant son
poste de télé alors si on fait beaucoup
de mouvement on se rendra compte que la
puissance moyenne d'un organisme humain
qui est en train de travailler se
baladent quelque part entre 10 et 100
watts
c'est ça qu'on va constater alors 100
watts et par exemple quelqu'un qui fait
l'ascension chamonix mont blanc dans la
journée le haut du mont blanc même si le
mont blanc est pas chez vous je pense
que vous voyez à peu près de quoi je
parle
et pour les parisiens même qui n'aiment
pas ça comme mélanie ça veut dire que
vous montez que je dise pas de conneries
13 fois dans la journée en haut de la
tour eiffel à pied 1 13 fois très si
vous faites 13 fois l'aller-retour
parvis tour eiffel à pied eh ben ça
c'est une puissance moyenne de 100 watts
que vos jambes développe dans la journée
ça vous donne une petite idée et si vous
faites un très grand trou pour de très
très gros géraniums et que vous décaissé
15 tonnes de terre dans la journée la
cédille watts de puissance moyenne pour
vos bras et les muscles du dos et les
ampoules
donc voyez un être humain au travail
si entre 10 et 100 watts alors
maintenant je vais prendre un mixeur à
soupe ou est ce que c'est un big sera
souple qui a déjà mixé de la soupe ici
il ya des mains qui se lèvent pas il ya
des gens qui ont jamais mis cette soupe
ici où ils écoutent pas non quand même
pas
c'est le truc qui fait pschitt là à
votre avis quand vous appuyez sur le
bouton il faudrait combien de personnes
qui pédalent pour mixer la soupe avec la
même puissance 20 vous avez un mixeur en
or en argent massif
ouais 3 3 4 c'est quand même beaucoup un
goût ça veut dire que quand vous appuyez
sur le bouton de ce véhicule machin tout
petits la qui fait pschitt
en fait vous avez la même puissance qui
se libèrent que si vous aviez
instantanément cadre domestique qui
arrivait et qui pédalait pour vous mais
juste c'est pas le même prix un plan les
enfants c'est moi
c'est pas le même prix alors maintenant
après être passés à table vous ai mis
des billes est partout où vous passez
l'aspirateur
alors au moment où vous passez
l'aspirateur là combien de personnes qui
pédalent pour vous 3000 watts non ça
c'est un aspirateur industriel ça non en
entre 6 et 10 à l'aspirateur maintenance
et 600 watts 1000 watts entre 6 et 10 un
bouton d'ascenseur
combien de personnes qui pédalent dans
la cave pour faire monter l'ascenseur
pas mal alors ces passants mais c'est 50
ça fait 5 kilowatts un gros un moteur
d'ascenseur 50 personnes qui se mettent
à pédaler dans la cave
quand vous appuyez sur le bouton de
l'ascenseur en impose
alors maintenant un engin que vous
croisez probablement de temps en temps
par chez vous c'est paris c'est un peu
plus rares un tracteur est bien quand le
conducteur du tracteur monde dans la
cabine de pilotage du tracteur et ça
c'est un petit tracteur parce qu'un
tracteur de gros céréaliers ses plus
puissants que ça eh bien vous avez des
centaines de paires de jambes qui se
mettent à pédaler pour lui
instantanément et si je prenais non pas
des jambes mais des chevaux et bien un
facteur de 60 kilowatts d'un petit
tracteur c'est 90 chevaux attelés qui se
mettent à tirer tout d'un coup 90 juste
un petit tracteur comme ça maintenant on
va prendre un engin de chantier
indispensable pour que les élus puissent
bétonné n'ont pas changé rien dit et qui
développe donc une centaine de kilowatts
de puissance
eh bien vous voyez là c'est comme si
vous mettiez instantanément la totalité
de la population de sablé au travail
avec des pelles et des pioches un seul
engin un seul engin c'est grâce à ça
qu'on peut terrasser un terrain en
quelques heures alors que dans les temps
anciens avec juste des pelles et des
pioches ce après des semaines
ça c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
on peut aujourd'hui se faire construire
un logement pour quelques années de
salaire
chose qui était juste impensable il ya
deux siècles c'était juste totalement
impensable il ya deux siècles et du
reste l'étalement urbain il ya deux
siècles c'était pas vraiment un problème
est la raison pour laquelle c'est devenu
accessible à toutes les bourses
l'étalement urbain
c'est notamment ça
voilà le camion dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure alors le camion lui
[ __ ] comme quelques milliers de fois
les jambes de son conducteur quelques
milliers de fois les jambes de son
conducteur
donc pour assurer l'approvisionnement
alimentaire par exemple de devil delà du
pays eh bien à chaque fois que vous
voyez un camion imaginez que vous leur
en place y est par un attelage de
quelques milliers de personnes en train
de pédaler
c'est ça la réalité physique de la
puissance qui est capable de développer
un camion et alors là tout ça c'est
ridicule maintenant on va parler de
trucs un peu plus sérieux un avion cette
fois ci c'est un million de fois les
jambes du pilote vers le pilote pourtant
il est en forme il est bronzé les jeunes
et c'est un million de fois les jambes
du pilote
et si vous prenez un laminoir et bien à
laminoir lui il est capable d'écraser la
tôle avec la même puissance musculaire
que un sixième de la population
française un sixième de la population
française on a deux ou trois laminoir en
france on en a au moins dunkerque et à
fos sur mer alors à laquelle je vous
parle il ya une personne dans la cabine
de pilotage du laminoir d'accord
une personne s'est des installations qui
tous qui tournent 24 heures sur 24 mais
une personne alors évidemment il ya
plein de gens autour
maintenant ce narrateur une personne
dans la cabine donc lui quand il rentre
dans la cabine de pilotage de son
laminoir c'est vraiment iron man à tous
les sens du terme du reste parce que
c'est iron dôme
c'est vraiment ça d'accord donc c'est
pour remplacer les deux laminoirs
français si je les avais pas j'aurai
besoin de la quasi totalité de la
population active française c'est à dire
20 millions de personnes rien que pour
taper sur des tôles toute la journée
tous autant que vous êtes vous avez
utilisé cet esclave énergétique là vous
avez des montures de lunettes en acier
des boutons de culotte en acier sauf
dans la guerre des boutons vous avez des
fourchettes chez vous des cuillères des
couteaux vous êtes venus en voiture tous
assez de l'acier donc tous autant que
vous êtes moi aussi un on a utilisé ses
esclaves mécanique des temps modernes
alors si je fais un petit calcul d'ordre
de grandeur avec toutes ces puissances
faramineuse de toutes ces machines qui
travaillent pas nécessairement tout en
même temps que nous avons maintenant à
notre disposition
eh bien on se rend compte que ces
machines avec leur croquettes pour
machines particulière c'est à dire
l'énergie
elles sont capables de développer en
moyenne sur l'année 200 fois la
puissance musculaire de l'humanité alors
maintenant je vais vous le dire
autrement si nous n'avions pas les
machines votre pouvoir d'achat serait
divisé instantanément par 200 [ __ ]
instantanément par deux sens enfin le
vôtre le vient instantanément ce qui
fait aujourd'hui la production
économique c'est plus du tout les gens
du reste des gens en a trop fait pour ce
qui est du chômage partout telle machine
le premier facteur limitant de la
production aujourd'hui c'est la quantité
de machines au travail et la quantité de
machines au travail c'est l'énergie
c'est pour ça que je reviendrai c'est
pour ça que c'est l'énergie qui pilotent
l'économie en france
le facteur multiplicatif et pas de 200
il est plutôt de six ans alors je vais
vous le dire autrement ça veut dire
qu'un français ordinaires moyens qui
n'existe pas comme chacun sait eh bien
il vit de la même manière s'il avait pas
de machine il faudrait 6 en esclavage 24
pour qu'ils vivent de la même manière
donc l'énergie
c'est le 20e siècle c'est pas un morceau
un truc qui s'est passé non
l'énergie c'est le 20ème siècle sans
énergie nous ne serions pas dans cette
salle on serait éreintés après une
journée de labeur à ramasser des patates
voilà on serait en ce moment c'est
l'énergie c'est le 20ème siècle
alors évidemment ce que je vous dis ça
déforme un tout petit peu la manière
qu'on doit avoir de regarder l'économie
l'économie vous avez apprise à l'école
et moi aussi
le reste est celle dont on vous parle
dans les débats politiques auxquels vous
participez peut-être de temps en temps
elle dit les choses de la manière
suivante vous avez un système productif
celui qui produit les fameuses richesses
alors ce système productif il a deux
facteurs de production les gens qui
travaillent et le capital et si vous
avez du capital grand et méchant comme
chacun sait est des gens qui travaillent
à ce moment vous avez une production et
supermarchés et remplit ses salles est
né à l'économie vous avez apprise à
l'école et c'est ça l'économie que j'ai
appris à l'école
donc si la production n'est pas assez
forte qu'est ce qu'on fait on botte le
cul des gens qui travaillent pas en leur
disant travail feignants et ont dit aux
banquiers arrête de faire n'importe quoi
investit dans l'économie réelle alors en
fait ces deux choses là on essaye de les
faire depuis 2008
et comme vous pouvez le constater ça ne
suffit pas à faire repartir la
production économique de manière
significative
indépendamment du coc vide c'est donc
probablement que le système est pas
aussi simple que ça alors en fait si
vous demandez à une personne j'allais
dire à l'ingénieur même pas une personne
de simple bon sens de regarder
physiquement le truc qui va vous dire ma
temps pour avoir le tout ce qui compose
ces objets là alors il a bien fallu les
prendre quelque part un verre ça se crée
pas d'un coup de baguette magique faut
bien les matières pour faire le vert un
fauteuil ça se crée pas d'un coup de
baguette magique en face au fcz et harry
potter mais sinon il faut bien les
matières etc
donc il va me falloir quelque part sur
terre la matière que je vais pouvoir
transformer en objet c'est ce qu'on
appelle les ressources naturelles
et puis il faut quelque part sur terre
aussi la capacité à transformer ses
ressources et c'est ça que je vais
appeler du travail le travail c'est la
transformation de ce que je fais autour
de moi et en fait cette transformation
avec ce que je viens de vous expliquer
vous comprenez que y'en a une toute
petite partie qu'on fait nous et
l'essentiel est fait par les machines et
leur croquettes pour machines alors une
fois que je vous ai montré ça vous
comprenez qu'il ya d'autres facteurs
limitants dans l'économie et en
particulier s'il ya un moment où on
manque d'énergie que ce soit pour des
raisons climatiques c'est-à-dire on
s'impose d'avoir moins d'énergie où que
ce soit pour des raisons géologiques a
pu tiens au fait un trou il ya plus de
pétrole
et bien à ce moment vous aurez moins de
production alors en fait les deux sont
valables et ce qui a déjà commencé à se
passer à petite vitesse en europe c'est
le a pu quand on fait un trou dans le
sol mais j'y viendrai tout à fait à la
fin de
de ma présentation et puis autre facteur
limitant qui peut s'appliquer il ya plus
de ressources à ce moment il ya plus
deux transformations
si vous avez plus de pétrole vous faites
plus plastique et à ce moment on fait
plus de fauteuils en plastique et en
fibres synthétiques
dès que vous avez des fibres
synthétiques quelque part c'est un
dérivé du pétrole donc nylon désolé
mesdames c'est du pétrole polyester en
polyuréthane enfin tous les pôle image
un chouette la sas et du pétrole donc le
du pétrole y en a absolument partout en
terme en matière première également pas
seulement en énergie et donc là ça vous
explique pourquoi je vous ai montré
cette courbe là tout à l'heure vous
voyez le premier déterminant dans ce
graphique c'est la quantité d'énergie
dont on dispose c'est ça le premier
facteur limitant puis on a plus on a des
machines au travail plus en transformer
source
plus on fait de plus on fait de
production plus le pib augmente c'est
exactement ça que je vous ai montré là
et au lieu de lire énergie en bas il
faut lire quantité de machines qui
travaillent en fait dès que vous voyez
énergie à partir de maintenant penser
machine au travail c'est sa l'énergie
c'est une machine au travail alors comme
cette énergie et fossiles elle a
également une conséquence c'est qu'elle
nous a conduits à augmenter très
fortement les émissions dites de gaz à
effet de serre alors un gaz à effet de
serre à nouveau je vais vous assommer
avec un peu de physique mais
malheureusement il faut le comprendre un
gaz à effet de serre ça une définition
physique très précise c'est un gaz qui
absorbe le rayonnement infrarouge émis
par la surface de la planète
vous savez que tous les corps maîtres du
rayonnement le soleil émet du
rayonnement visible qui pour ça qu'on le
voit il aimait également du rayonnement
ultraviolet
au delà du visible 1 avec des
rayonnements qui sont plus énergétiques
longueur d'onde plus courte il aimait
également de l'infrarouge b de
l'infrarouge à courte longueur d'onde
celui qui fait qu' on sent la chaleur et
la terre qui est pas du tout à la
température du soleil du reste
heureusement pour nous parce que civil
degrés il fera un peu chaud elle aimait
aussi du rayonnement mais du rayonnement
moins énergétiques puisqu'elle est moins
chaudes et qu'on appelle de l'infrarouge
lointain
c'est ça que j'aimais la terre est bien
le rayonnement de la terre il est
intercepté dans l'atmosphère par ce
qu'on appelle les gaz à effet de serre
c'est ça leur définition à gaz à effet
de serre c'est un gaz qui est capable
d'absorber qui est opaque aux
infrarouges terrestre
exactement comme le dossier de votre
fauteuil et opaques à la lumière voilà
c'est même processus vous envoyer du
rayonnement lumineux de suite absorbé
passe pas à travers et bien les gaz à
effet de serre vous envoyer du
rayonnement infrarouge émis par la terre
dedans et ça passe pas à travers faut
que ça passe mal à travers il est
absorbé et donc plus jamais de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère plus le
rayonnement émis par la planète a du mal
à s'échapper vers l'espace et plus ça
chauffe
il ya de l'énergie qui est confiné près
de la surface alors ça chauffe mais pas
que il ya des tas d'autres déséquilibres
qui apparaissent ici vous avez les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'humanité depuis un siècle et demi
alors là vous avez le co2 qui augmente
essentiellement à cause de l' usage de
l'énergie fossile croissant mais aussi à
cause de la déforestation la
déforestation est une des cause
d'émission de co2 et au dessus vous avez
un gaz qui s'appelle le méthane qui a
d'autres origines notamment agricoles
alors vous pouvez aussi sur cette courbe
je voulais pas remis sur l'énergie mais
voilà mettre d'autres trucs qui sont
censés nous des carbo dévoyé par exemple
électricité ça fait plus d'un siècle
qu'on s'en sert sa pas empêché les
émissions d'augmenter l'informatique ça
fait longtemps qu'on s'en sert ça n'a
pas empêché les émissions d'augmenter
pareil en ce qui concerne les trains
pareil en ce qui concerne internet est
pareil enfin continue d'augmenter
alors il ya une très mauvaise nouvelle
en ce qui concerne les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et en particulier les
émissions de co2 c'est que le co2 il est
éternel
une fois qu'on l'a mis dans l'air le co2
est un oxyde c'est dioxyde de carbone
c'est ça que maintenant on dit à vos
bambins d'apprendre à l'école on leur
interdit de dire gaz carbonique s'est
défendu ils se font taper sur les doigts
qu'une règle maintenant on dit dioxyde
de carbone alors les oxydes sur terre
sont des formes très stable
chimiquement très stable il ya un oxyde
dont vous vous servez tous les jours en
tout cas si vous voulez pas sentir
mauvais qui est loch site de dihydrogène
c'est-à-dire l'eau tous les jours
normalement prenez une douche mais
pourquoi bon bref c'est pas bien voilà
pour pas sortir mollet et bien l'eau ça
fait des milliards d'années que c'est
sur terre sous forme d'eau solide un pas
beaucoup de couples sur terre qui dure
des milliards d'années même les deux là
bas quand même pas dû être à côté l'un
de l'autre
donc les oxydes c'est des molécules qui
sont chimiquement très très stable et le
co2 n'y fait pas exception
donc une fois que vous le mettez dans
l'air il n'y a rien qui l'enlève
directement tant qu'il est au milieu de
l'atmosphère
rien pour que le co2 veuille bien
ressortir de l'atmosphère
il faut qu'ils reviennent au contact du
sol où là il peut lui arriver
l'une des deux shows suivante il est
absorbé par vos géraniums donc c'est la
photosynthèse
à ce moment le co2 est repris à lherm et
par contact avec les feuilles de la
plante
d'accord il n'est pas au milieu de l'air
en contact avec rien il y est ça a
besoin d'énergie pour fonctionner pour
ça qu on appelle la photosynthèse vous
avez besoin du photon de la lumière du
soleil
ces salles apport d'énergie qui permet à
la molécule de co2 d'être cassé sinon si
vous essayez de faire pousser des
plantes illégale dans un placard sans
éclairage ça marche pas donc savoir que
montre bien qu'il faut de l'énergie et
enfin la deuxième manière que le co2
peut être peut avoir d'être free à
l'atmosphère c'est d'être dissous dans
l'eau océanique et ça c'est juste une
affaire de vases communicants d'accord
l'eau peut être dissout dans l'air va
peut être contenue dans l'air et peut
être contenu dans l'eau si en proportion
il y en a plus dans l'air que dans l'eau
au bypass dans l'eau pour partie mais
c'est réversible
s'il ya un moment la concentration dans
l'air diminue pas ce qu'ont réussi à
leur faire ressortir une partie de celui
qui est passé dans l'eau ressort de
l'eau c'est un processus de vases
communicants
à cause de ce que je viens de vous dire
voilà le drame
enfin oui bon on peut dire le drame du
changement climatique
ce que vous dit cette courbe c'est
qu'elles vous donnent la fraction d'un
surplus de co2 qu'on a créés au cours du
temps après arrêt des émissions dit
autrement vous on a créé un surplus de
co2 avec les émissions de co2 qu'on a
fait dans l'atmosphère donc il ya plus
de co2 aujourd'hui qu'il ya un siècle
question ce plus de co2 en combien de
temps ils s'évacue si on arrête des
maîtres et bien cette cour vous donne la
réponse au bout d'un siècle
il vous reste encore quasiment la moitié
de votre surplus au bout d'un millier
d'années il vous en reste entre 20 et
30% et au bout de dix mille ans il vous
en reste encore 10 et 20 entre 10 et 20%
l'atmosphère pour le restant des temps
historiques ne reviendra jamais dans
l'état dans lequel elle était en 1750
jamais ce qui veut dire que le système
climatique
d'une certaine manière ne reviendra
jamais pour les temps qu'il reste à
l'humanité à vivre dans l'état dans
lequel il était avant le début de la
civilisation industrielle jamais donc
l'idée que la pollution climatique est
une pollution qu'on peut supprimer en
prenant les mesures appropriées et
malheureusement une idée qu'il faut se
sortir de la tête
on peut l'atténuer et il faut le faire
mais il ya une partie de l'héritage du
passé qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus
refuser du tout on va se le payer de
toute façon c'est ça qui vous explique
pourquoi le climat à l'avenir va
continuer à dériver quoi qu'on fasse il
dérivera d'autant plus vite que on
essaiera de profiter de l'énergie
fossile tant que ça passe mais on ne
peut plus empêcher cette dérive de
survenir désormais une autre manière de
dire ça c'est que le climat de l'an 2000
est perdue à jamais déjà il a perdu à
jamais faut s'y faire enfin faut s'y
faire
faut le prendre en compte alors bien
évidemment ce problème là s'échelonne
sur des pas de temps qu'ils sont hors de
l'entendement c'est un des problèmes
qu'on a ça va très au delà d'une ou
plusieurs vies humaines et surtout ça va
très très au delà d'un mandat d'élu
quel qu'il soit quel qu'il soit ça va
aussi très au delà de la stratégie long
terme dans une entreprise cotée qui se
balade entre 6 mois et 3 ans ça se
balade très au delà des pâtes temps avec
lesquels on a l'habitude de gérer nos
affaires aujourd'hui donc un des
problèmes du changement climatique
c'est ce qu'on appelle la tragédie des
horizons c'est à dire le fait que les
pathans caractéristiques du problème
sont en complet décalage avec les pas de
temps des organes de gestion que nous
avons mis en place aucun élu dans cette
salle ne va prendre en compte ce que
sera la planète en 2080 dans son
rome électorale enfin où ça va peser
très très peu voilà donc c'est ça un des
problèmes alors je mets plus de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère du coup
l'atmosphère garde plus d'énergie près
du sol et la température moyenne au sol
augmente c'est exactement ce que vous
montre cette courbe alors cette courbe
elle part de 1850 et elle vous donne la
température moyenne de la planète alors
le par convention le 0 c la température
sur 7 sur la dernière moitié du 19e
siècle et vous voyez qu'au 19e siècle la
température on n'aimait pas encore
beaucoup de co2 dans l'atmosphère donc
ça va encore à peu près et puis au 20e
siècle la température moyenne commence à
s'élever et alors à laquelle je vous
parle on a gagné à peu près 1,2 degré
par rapport à l'époque préindustrielle
0,2 degré bon ben voilà bon 1 soit alors
soit c'est déjà suffisant pour que 15 à
20% des coraux soit mort sur terre c'est
déjà suffisant pour que ça ait contribué
à ce qu'un tiers de la superficie
française et brûlé en australie il ya un
an un tiers de la superficie française
quand même une surface presque
équivalente en sibérie la même année
allez cette fois ci plus de seulement
10% ridicule de la superficie française
en californie a brûlé et puis encore la
même année au pénal ça a brûlé aussi
enfin bon bref
donc c'est déjà suffisant pour que ça
déclenche que ça favorise de manière
massive des feux de forêts dans le monde
c'est suffisant pour avoir contribué en
j'ai pas le temps aujourd'hui mais j'ai
une conférence qui tourne sur internet
qui s'appelle de dèche à la coupe 21 si
ça vous intéresse d'aller regarder je
décortique pas à pas en quoi cela va
contribuer au printemps arabe également
et à la au déclenchement des troubles en
syrie
évidemment c'est une goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase c'est pas ça fait pas
déborder le vase à lui tout seul mais ça
a été un contributeur
c'était un déclencheur c'est suffisant
pour avoir contribué à une baisse de la
récolte de pommes de terre de 40% en
france il ya deux ans et voilà on
commence à en avoir des traductions
aujourd'hui c'est suffisant pour avoir
flingué une quantité significative
d'épicéa dans les vosges donc enfin ça
commence à arriver
c'est 1,2 degré 1 c'est plus de
totalement virtuelle cette histoire est
ce que vous voyez c'est à l'avenir
quelle pourrait-être l'élévation de
température moyenne en fonction de ce
que nous allons faire donc ça c'est le
scénario mélanie cogner voyez on est on
voit pas la souris alors pardon c'est le
en jaune la scénario mélanie collier
donc c'est un scénario dix accords de
paris c'est le scénario dans lequel très
très vite on appuie sur la [ __ ] de
frein en ce qui concerne les émissions
le scénario rouge
c'est le scénario croissance infinie
dans lequel on aimait de plus en plus de
co2 parce que on a une économie de plus
en plus florissante entre guillemets et
aucun facteur limitant à l'économie
jusqu'en 2100 c'est à dire ni le
changement climatique ni l'absence de
combustibles fossiles ni l'absence de
ressources ni rien et voilà ni
l'invasion des martiens nos gènes la
croissance d'économies jusqu'en 2100
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que
l'élévation de température en 2100 et
très discriminés en fonction de ce qu'on
va faire sur les émissions par contre ce
que vous voyez c'est que pour les 20
années à venir
il ya quasiment pas de différence selon
la couleur de la courbe c'est la
conséquence de la grande inertie du co2
dans l'atmosphère dont je vous ai parlé
en fait quel que soit le scénario la
dérive des 20 prochaines années elle est
déjà embarqué c'est ça qu'il faut avoir
en tête
ce qui veut dire que non seulement il va
falloir s'occuper de baisser les
émissions pour qu'à l'arrivée on soit
plus près de la cour john que la courbe
rouge mais en plus il va falloir
commencer à gérer des désordres
croissants et qui vont continuer à
s'amplifier et qui vont continuer à
s'amplifier dans les décennies à venir
de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse
changement climatique c'est un peu comme
une voiture pour laquelle obama où vous
appuyer sur la [ __ ] de frein le
premier truc que fait la voiture c'est
de continuer à accélérer pendant 20 ans
c'est ça le sait ça le parallèle qu'il
faut avoir en tête
alors est-ce que quelques degrés c'est
beaucoup c'est peu je vais essayer de
répondre à cette question avec une
petite comparaison historique
vous avez ici le genre d'écosystèmes
qu'on trouve en europe
avant on va dire le début du 21e siècle
à condition qu'on leur fasse pas des
misères pour mettre autre chose à la
place alors le autre chose ça a été
essentiellement des cultures mais
également des infrastructures etc
vous voyez que nous avons
essentiellement des forêts ça veut dire
que le climat est suffisamment doux et
enfin pâte ni trop chaud ni trop ni trop
froid et surtout suffisamment humide
pour qui y poussent des gros espèces
végétales
voilà l'europe ya vingt mille ans alors
il ya vingt mille ans dans le cadre des
variations climatiques naturelles parce
que le climat a toujours varié
naturellement par la même vitesse que
aujourd'hui mais il a toujours varié
naturellement l'europe est beaucoup plus
froides on est au coeur de la dernière
ère glaciaire
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que le
paysage est fin bonne nouvelle pour ceux
qui aiment le rugby
les irlandais les écossais étaient aussi
sous la place vous voyez alors pour
faire toutes ces grosses calotte de
glace celle posée sur la scandinavie sur
le canada il y en a également une sur la
sibérie il faut bien avoir pris l'eau
quelque part un tous ceux d'entre vous
qui font des glaçons dans le frigo
savent qu'en général ça vaut pas il faut
prendre de l'eau pour faire les glaçons
alors l'eau qui a permis de faire ces
énormes glaçons elle vient de l'océan il
ya eu un énorme transfert d'eau par
évaporation et précipitations sous forme
de neige très longtemps entre l'océan et
les continents et du coup le niveau des
océans a baissé de 120 mètres puisque le
silence une grande baignoire et si vous
retirez loba le niveau de la baignoire
baisse et donc pas de bauxite puisqu'il
ya une continuité territoriale entre la
france et la grande-bretagne pas de
paradis fiscaux dans les anglo normandes
puisqu'elle plus anglo normandes pas
d'éoliennes offshore en mer du nord
puisqu'il n'ya pas de mer du nord
donc vous voyez que le trait de côte et
très très différent de ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
le climat étant beaucoup plus froid il
est beaucoup plus sec
vous savez quand le climat est très
froid en général il ya peu de
précipitation parce qu'il ya peu
d'évaporation un climat très froid est
un climat dans lequel il ya peu
d'évaporation peu de précipitation
et donc les écosystèmes à l'époque ils
sont froids et peu arrosée ils sont
maigrichon et ils ressemblent à ce que
vous avez aujourd'hui au nord de la
sibérie
voilà à quoi ressemble les écosystèmes
de l'époque et enfin à cette époque là
la totalité de la population française
est bien inférieure à celle du monde
l'agglomération du mans puisque la
population française dans son ensemble
fait cent mille personnes
en gros on le recensement était pas très
précis l'insee était un peu moins
performante mais en gros 100 mille
personnes quand l'europe est passée de
l'état de gauche à l'état de droite ça
s'est fait dans le cadre d'un
réchauffement planétaire global êtes
d'accord avec moi que faire fondre un
glaçon en le refroidissant ça marche
moyen donc il ya eu un réchauffement
planétaire et bien ce réchauffement
planétaire
il est juste de 5° en dividende donc là
vous avez le résultat d'une expérience
grandeur nature qu'on est capable de
reconstituer avec des analyses du passé
qui vous montre à quoi ressemble
l'évolution de l'environnement avec un
réchauffement de 5° en dix mille ans
vous pouvez me dire à ces cinq degrés
c'est vachement bien parce que au moment
de la dernière ère glaciaire l'europe
était un cultivables maintenant elle est
cultivable c'est quand même vachement
mieux je vais vous dire oui très bien
ce raisonnement a quand même des limites
prendre 20 ans entre 0 et 20 en ce qui
vous concerne c' était une très bonne
affaire entre 50 et 70 ça doit pour le
moment se discuter un peu plus donc une
élévation de température n'a pas
toujours le même bénéfice
quel que soit le point de départ est par
ailleurs ça n'a surtout pas le même
bénéfice quelle que soit la durée
d'application donc là si on parle de
quelques degrés en un siècle c'est un
réchauffement 100 fois plus brutal que
celui qu'on a eu à cette époque là donc
je vais vous le dire très très vite
parce que j'ai pas le temps de détailler
les conséquences ce soir la conséquence
qu'il faut retenir de un réchauffement
de quelques degrés en un siècle
c'est pas on va mettre un pull de plus
ou de moins et on va s'employer pour
savoir si les écolos sont des gens
fréquentables ou pas ça sera la guerre
partout c'est ça quelques degrés de plus
en un siècle
ça sera la guerre partout ça sera
l'effondrement des structures politiques
stables
sous les coups de boutoir d'un défaut de
ressources qui s'appliquera de manière
massive à 8 milliards d'hommes
sédentaires sur terre donc le
réchauffement climatique
c'est pas quelque chose qui est juste un
problème
d'inconfort ou éventuellement de
pommiers qui crèvent dans le jardin puis
pas très grave on mettra autre chose à
la place
non on est en train de parler de quelque
chose qui a la capacité à handicaper
l'approvisionnement alimentaire d'un
certain nombre de milliards d'hommes et
vous savez que quand on commence à avoir
des problèmes alimentaires en général
les gens laissent pas tranquille ça la
capacité de porter atteinte aux
infrastructures de façon absolument
massive et c'est donc en fait ça va
provoquer des désorganisations est ce
qu'il faut garder en tête sur ces
désorganisation c'est que ça arrivera
pas de manière tranquille et prévisible
ça vous fera déco vide c'est-à-dire
dimanche tu circulent l'indiqué
claquemuré chez toi dimanche tout allait
bien lundi ça va plus ça va arriver par
marche d'escalier cette affaire ça va
arriver par marche d'escalier
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir en tête et par
ailleurs comme l'expérience est inédite
il ya eu la conférence qui tout sur
internet auquel je vous renvoie pour
avoir des conséquences plus détaillées
tout ça il faut pas s'imaginer une seule
seconde que la science est capable de
vous donner par le menu toutes les
conséquences possibles en fonction des
degrés de réchauffement à 3 52 degrés de
réchauffement en un siècle alors je
risque très exactement ceci sur la perte
d'approvisionnement alimentaire en 2075
est très exactement le 3 juillet non
vous trouverez jamais des trucs comme ça
ça n'a aucun sens ce qui veut dire que
si on essaye de mener l'expérience
jusqu'à son terme ce qu'on va avoir
c'est essentiellement des surprises
évidemment des mauvaises surprises et le
dictionnaire étant bien fait une
surprise c'est un truc pour lequel on
n'a pas eu le temps de s'organiser
c'est bien pour ça que je vous disais
tout à l'heure ça prépare ce genre de
truc si on va jusqu'à son terme
quelque chose qui ressemble plus à des
effondrements locaux ou régionaux que à
bosser un peu inconfortable
on mettra la clim dans les villes pour
passer les vagues de chaud et puis voilà
ça ira bien quoi c'est pas du tout ça
qui nous attend
alors si on veut éviter le gag qu'est-ce
qu'il faut avoir comme ordre de grandeur
en tête et c'est là dessus que je
terminais vous avez ici une courbe qui a
été enfin graphique qui a été sorti par
le gia qui a maintenant sept ans et qui
vous donne la réponse du système
climatique en température celle axe
vertical en fonction de la quantité
totale de co2 qu'on met dans
l'atmosphère c'est la courbe horizontale
alors plus exactement la quantité totale
de co2 con mais jusqu'en 2100 donc on
démarre au moment où on joue avec la
machine à vapeur pour la première fois
et on va jusqu'en 2100 ça c'est la
courbe du haut c'est des milliards de
tonnes de co2 et ça vous dit de combien
la planète va se réchauffer c'est
l'échelle de gauche
à ce moment là en fonction de nos
émissions alors pour donner un tour un
peu concrets afin 2018
on avait mis dans l'air 2200 milliards
de tonnes de co2 depuis le début de
l'ère industrielle en jouant avec la
machine à vapeur la machine à pétrole et
la machine à gaz et donc ce graphique
vous dit que l'atmosphère température
planétaire va se réchauffer d'à peu près
1,5 degré si on veut se limiter à 2
degrés à ce moment on fait le chemin
inverse on dit bah voilà on a le droit
d'émettre 3000 milliards de tonnes de
co2 dont 2200 ont déjà été émises et
pour l'essentiel depuis 1945
c'est à dire il ya 80 ans il se trouve
qu'on est en 2020 fin 2021
donc il reste 80 ans jusqu'en 2100 il se
trouve que 800 c'est à peu près le tiers
de 2200 d'accord donc ça veut dire que
pour les 80 ans qui nous restent
jusqu'en 2100 l'humanité a
collectivement le droit d'émettre le
tiers de ce qu'elle a émis sur les 80
ans qui viennent de s'écouler à une
époque où la population planétaire était
en ordre de grandeur 2,5 fois moins
nombreuses dans l'ensemble de la période
je vais vous le dire autrement ça veut
dire qu'un papier ou une mamie qui
meurent aujourd'hui à 80 ans a émis sur
sa vie c'est
neuf fois plus de co2 que ce qu'un bébé
qui naît aujourd'hui a le droit d'en
émettre sur sa vie sept à neuf fois plus
voilà c'est ça les deux degrés de
l'accord de paris c'est qu'un bébé qui
naît aujourd'hui sur sa vie il a le
droit d'émettre le neuvième de ce que
ses grands-parents qui meurent
aujourd'hui on est mis sur leur vie ça
c'est l'accord de paris alors vous
comprenez bien il faut que je vous ai
dit ça que ça va pas se faire en un
claquement de doigts et vous comprenez
bien avec ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure sur l'importance des
combustibles fossiles dans ce qui a fait
parce que les combustibles fossiles
c'est le monde dans lequel on vit
c'est le monde dans lequel on vit eh
bien vous comprenez bien que ça va pas
se faire sans toucher à tous partout et
sans toucher en particulier à notre
sacro-saint pouvoir d'achat et en
particulier si on veut que ça marche
à partir de maintenant il faut que tous
les ans les émissions baisse sur terre
d'environ 5% par an et 5 % de baisse sur
une année c'est ce qu'on a eu en 2020
avec l'année avec le co vide
donc en gros les accords de paris c'est
un coït de plus tous les ans on va dire
non
très bien dehors allant voir un coup
tant qu'il y en a on peut parler écouter
alors j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous
il ya également une voiture balai la
voiture balai s'appelle la déplétion des
combustibles fossiles car quand vous
avez un quelque chose qui mec 50 à 400
millions d'années à se former
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que c'est
difficilement qualifiable de
renouvelables aux échelles de temps qui
nous intéresse c'est très renouvelables
à l'échelle de 50 millions d'années mais
bon comme nous on vit un peu moins
longtemps que ça à nos échelles de temps
c'est pas renouvelable ça veut dire que
vous pouvez pas en avoir indéfiniment
plus qui sort du sous sol
c'est pas possible en fait les
mathématiques vous l'interdît et alors
là vous avez un document qui a été
publié en 2018 par l' agence
internationale de l'énergie qui est
passé beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus bas dans l'écran radar des
médias que à peu près n'importe quel
chien écrasé dans n'importe quel village
de france mais qui vous dit un tout
petit truc juste un tout petit truc qui
vous dit la [ __ ] la production de
pétrole conventionnel
c'est à dire tout ce qui n'est pas le
pétrole de schiste aux états unis et les
sables bitumineux au canada est passé
par un maximum mondiale en 2008 et sa
décline depuis qu'ils étaient au courant
dans la salle d'apparat par les
ayatollahs comme moi la personne
bon donc ça fait plus de dix ans que
l'approvisionnement pétrolier décline
dans le monde et il décline pas parce
que on a peur du changement climatique
il décline juste parce que le maximum
des découvertes de pétrole ça s'est
passé à peu de choses près l'année de ma
naissance que depuis sa décline et que
pour faire sortir du pétrole de terre
faut quand même commencé par découvrir
si vous savez pas où il est compliqué de
le faire sortir
et voilà en parlant de sortir quelque
chose qui sort du four qui est un
graphique issu d'un travail que le
chiffre project a publié en fin ou à
effectuer plus exactement avec l'argent
du ministère des armées
donc on a des fréquentations pas avoir
blanchi project on a réussi à obtenir un
peu d'argent du ministère des armées
pour aller travailler une base de
données extrêmement détaillées sur
l'ensemble des gisements pétroliers dans
le monde il ya trois sociétés dans le
monde qui détiennent des bases de
données très détaillées comme ça
l'abonnement annuel à ce genre de base
de données le tarif catalogue ces
quelques millions de dollars par an ou
doutez bien qu'on a pas cet argent
nous on a réussi à le négocier pour une
fraction 2 % de ce montant là mais on a
publié donc les résultats et le travail
a été fait par trois personnes qui
connaissent très bien le secteur dont
l'ancien patron de l'exploration de
total donc on peut pas nous dire que
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît pas le sujet
et le graphique vous l'avez là sur la
production de pétrole des 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'union européenne donc
on a pris les 16 premiers fournisseurs
de l'union européenne n'a regardé
combien de pétrole ils pouvaient
produire à l'avenir sur la base de tous
les gisements inventorier et ceux
restant à découvrir et c est le trait
c'est aujourd'hui
eh bien vous voyez que même en
estimation haute on ne revient pas à la
production preco vide 2019 et vous voyez
surtout que quelle que soit la
l'hypothèse qu'on fasse sur le shale oil
sur le pétrole de schiste aux états unis
ça descend et à un moment ça se met à
descendre très vite donc l'automobiliste
français que ça lui plaise ou que ça ne
plaise pas va devoir faire avec moins de
pétrole même si le changement climatique
y considère que c'est une lubie l'écolo
de toute façon de toute façon donc on va
être coincé à l'avenir entre le problème
climatique et le problème à l'amont de
ressources et c'est dans cet univers
compliqué désagréable qui empêche de
faire toutes les promesses électorales
qu'on veut qu'il va falloir qu'on
navigue alors avant de finir l'agencé
européenne de l'environnement a publié
en janvier dernier par l'agencé
européenne de l'environnement est une
institution officielle de l'union
exactement comme la cour de justice ou
comme la commission sais c'est pas c'est
pas une ong
donc l'agencé européenne de
l'environnement a sorti en janvier un
document qu'il a aussi passé totalement
sous les écrans radar et qui dit en gros
la croissance verte y en aura pas voilà
si vous savez lire entre les lignes
donc s'il ya de la croissance allait pas
verte est si sévère ya pas de croissance
je vous le dis très brutalement mais
c'est à peu près ça qu'elle dit et moi
je rajoute un deuxième truc qui est de
toute façon qu'on le veuille ou pas la
croissance c'est l'énergie et de
l'énergie il va y en avoir moins à un
moment ou un autre et à ce moment il y
aura plus de croissance et donc la
question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui
o'shea project et je finis avec ça c'est
comment est-ce qu'on ne désespère pas
billancourt dans un monde sans
croissance
et comment est ce qu'on fait pour régler
le problème climatique en ne comptant
pas sur de plus en plus de moyens pour
le faire c'est très exactement ça la
question qu'on se pose parce que à mon
sens c'est très exactement la question
qu'il faut se poser aujourd'hui elle
peut être très désagréable
peut-être que à la fin c'est exposer
vous vous dites que vous auriez mieux
fait de rester chez vous mais en
attendant c'est malheureusement très
exactement ça la question qu'il faut
qu'on se pose quand on a bien fait le
tour de ses contours physiques du
problème et j'ai été très bavard et donc
là je m'arrête mon train et demain matin
donc là vous pouvez y aller
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur jancovici on va prendre
les questions en ligne
enfin sur le téléphone à la volée est ce
que voulait qu'on répète le numéro est
ce qu'on peut l'affiché s'il vous plaît
monsieur garnier nom alors je leur donne
je retrouve ma fiche donc vous pouvez
nous envoyer des sms au 06 78 15 14 63
06 78 15 14 63 je le répèterai ans il
faut alors on va commencer avec la
première question alors aurait une
première question alors en revenant sur
le descriptif des différents types
d'énergie que vous avez présenté
quelqu'un pose la question suivante vous
disiez que du coup que photovoltaïque
sacré en gros 50 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure en tout cas c'est ce qu'il
fallait donc une remarque tout
simplement que vous allez pouvoir
peut-être argumenté cet interrogateur du
coup dis donc il est inutile de biais de
l'électricité verte puisque ça n'existe
pas finalement alors il ya beaucoup de
questions en fait dans cette affirmation
simple la première c est ce que ça a du
sens de mettre un adjectif derrière de
l'électricité en fait non l'électricité
elle est le côté vert est quelque chose
qui ne se manifeste pas dans
l'électricité
on peut quantifier les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre que l'on fait pour
produire un kilowattheure électrique ça
ça existe
après verts on peut décider que c'est à
partir de 50 grammes sévère à partir de
100 grammes de co2 par kilowattheure
sévère à partir de 400 ans et vert à
partir de deux sévères voilà donc versé
a pas de contenu normatif
si je vous donne les ordres de grandeur
en ce qui concerne la production
électrique qui sont les suivants pour
faire un kilowattheure au charbon c'est
1000 g 1 kg de co2 un kilowattheure au
gaz
c'est à peu près 400 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure électrique kilowattheure
au pétrole c'est à peu près 800 si vous
faites de l'électricité au pétrole il ya
encore un des turbines au fioul si vous
faites du photovoltaïque c'est à peu
près 50 vous allez dire le panneau
n'émet pas de co2 oui c'est tout à fait
vrai le panneau des mets pas de co2 par
contre il a fallu pour avoir
l'électricité photovoltaïque faire le
panneau alors faire le panneau
s'effondre du silicium sa demande de
l'énergie
c'est faire un cadre en acier sa demande
de l'énergie c'est mettre un onduleur ce
matin donc si vous regardez la totalité
de ce qu'il faut avoir pour que le
panneau puisse fonctionner et que vous
rapportez ça à la durée de vie du
panneau c'est comme ça que ça marche
une analyse et bien vous vous rendez
compte que sur sa durée de vie en france
parce que évidemment dans le désert
saoudien ça serait deux fois plus faible
puisque être deux fois plus de
production plus de soleil en norvège ça
serait deux fois plus fort parce que la
norvège est un pays un peu moins
insolent et que la côte d'azur
eh bien vous avez même que le pays
sartoux et bien vous avez un contenu
carbone pour le photovoltaïque en france
qui est de l'ordre de 50 grammes après
si je vais sur les barrages l'éolien et
le nucléaire on se promène aux alentours
de 10 un peu plus un peu moins ça dépend
sauf dans un cas très particulier du
barrage de petits sauts en guyane ou au
mans on a mis en eau le lac de barrage
on a noyé la végétation qui s'y
trouvaient elle se décompose en faisant
du méthane et si vous rapportez cette
production de méthane à la production
électrique du barrage le barrage de
petits sous en guyane aimer autant
qu'une centrale à gaz mais c'est
vraiment une bizarrerie on va dire dans
le monde des barrages du coup je vais en
profiter pour faire une un complément ça
veut dire qu'en france quand on dit
qu'on veut remplacer du nucléaire qui
est à 10 grammes de co2 par de l'éolien
et du solaire qui sont respectivement à
10 et à 50
c'est un débat hors climat c'est pas un
débat qui concerne la décarbonation de
la france alors c'est un débat hors
climat si vous remplacez un truc à 10
par un truc à 10 sur le plan du climat
c'est équivalent si vous remplacez un
truc à 10 par un truc à 50 sur le plan
du climat c'est même un peu moins
viens donc la seule justification à
faire baisser le nucléaire c'est si on
est tellement contre le nucléaire qu'on
veut n'importe quoi sur du nucléaire
mais c'est pas du tout une justification
qui va je vous le dis parce que le
discours officiel mélange à dessein les
deux en permanence discours
gouvernemental en ce moment est un joyau
gloubiboulga dans lequel les deux sont
mélangés en permanence mais c'est juste
ça pardon aussi un dernier truc que je
voulais dire sur l'électricité verte
quand vous pensez acheter de
l'électricité verte parce que vous
achetez un fournisseur d'électricité
verte
en fait vous n'achetez pas une
électricité différente de celle de votre
voisin vous êtes physiquement connectés
au même réseau que lui
donc en fait un distributeur
d'électricité verte ne vous vend pas un
produit qui est physiquement différent
du produit que vous achetez chez le
voisin
en fait tout le monde est sur le même
réseau un réseau électrique c'est très
simple c'est un gros abreuvoir dans
lequel vous avez plein de robinets
ouverts ça c'est les centrales
électriques et plein de tuyaux qui
soutire ça c'est les consommateurs et au
milieu vous avez le réseau qui est un
truc qui mutualisent non quand vous avez
200 robinet qui sont ouverts dans un
abreuvoir et 200 paille de gens qui
boivent dans l'abreuvoir est ce que vous
pouvez dire moi je bois l'eau de dell
robinet non vous buvez lot de
l'abreuvoir comme votre voisin d'accord
tout le monde boit la démo l'électricité
c'est exactement pareil
tout le monde utilise physiquement la
même électricité alors pourquoi se
compliquer les vertes
seul le mécanisme de verdissement entre
guillemets correspond à la chose
suivante les producteurs d'électricité
renouvelable en france qui ne
bénéficient pas d'un tarif d'achat
garanti star essentiellement les
barrages ont le droit de vendre
séparément leur kilowattheure est ce
qu'on appelle un certificat de garantie
d'origine c'est à dire le fait qu'il ya
un kilowattheure renouvelables qui
existe quelque part et ce certificat de
garantie d'origine va vivre sa vie
indépendamment du kilowattheure qui a
été vendu par le producteur
d'électricité renouvelable et donc le
distributeur d'électricité dite verte
l'achète ce certificat dont par exemple
total énergie et vous vend le certificat
avec le contrat de distribution
d'électricité mais qui en pratique fait
que vous restez physiquement branché au
même endroit du reste si vous avez
changé de distributeurs d'électricité
pas changé de branchement personne est
venu chez vous en disant attendez je
vous le débranche les trucs du réseau
l'appui je vais tirer un câble qui va
aller jusqu'à 100 bornes de là où se
trouvent les éoliennes ont produit tout
ce qui se passe ce qui se passe c'est
que vous restez branchés exactement au
même réseau vous conservez exactement la
même électricité
mais la convention qu'on vous appliquez
a juste changé d'accord mais cette
convention ne change pas la réalité
physique est en fait ces certificats de
garantie d'origine
c'est juste du profits additionnels pour
les détenteurs de barrage
essentiellement qui sont capables de
vendre ses certificats en plus je le
disais des kilowattheures voilà donc en
fait cette cette notion d'électricité
verte au sens de l'article qui vient
d'être amendé dans la loi climat à
l'assemblée nationale ça c'est plutôt
c'est une très bonne chose devrait être
interdite ça devrait être assimilé à de
la publicité mensongère
alors puisqu'on est sur les questions de
production d'énergie du coup une autre
question par rapport au biogaz est ce
que pour vous signale t relative qui
peut être viable
est ce que ça peut se faire en circuit
court voilà qu'est ce que vous pouvez
nous un terreau de su alors six jeux sur
le biogaz si je reprends si je tiens si
je me mets dans la continuité de la
réponse précédente
en france où les dit tout à l'heure
l'électricité et déjà décarbonée donc si
on se place dans une optique dans lequel
ce qui est la mienne ou la course contre
la montre elle est avant tout sur le
sujet climatique et avant tout sur la
dépendance à une énergie fossiles
importées qui sera pas éternelle la
première chose à laquelle le premier
problème auquel on s'attaque c'est les
énergies fossiles c'est pas
l'électricité nucléaire
mais encore une fois c'est mon point de
vue à ce moment les bonnes énergies
renouvelables sont celles qui permettent
de substituer les combustibles fossiles
alors qu'est ce qu'on a comme bonnes
énergies renouvelables qui permet de
substituer des combustibles fossiles
on a tous ceux qui dérive de la biomasse
dans la mesure où cette utilisé de
manière soutenable et en particulier il
peut y avoir le biogaz donc le biogaz
c'est quoi si vous prenez de la matière
organique vous fait fermenter ça comme
dans un vulgaire marécages sauf que vous
mettez ça dans un digesteur vous
récupérer le méthane
au lieu de ça vous fasse des feux
follets et à ce moment ce méthane vous
pouvez l'utiliser c'est comme du gaz
naturel c'est la même chose
vous pouvez l'utiliser pour un usage un
usage ou avant vous utilisez des
énergies fossiles alors de mon point de
vue le biogaz est intéressant le premier
usage pour lequel c'est intéressant
c'est de substituer les combustibles
fossiles dans le monde agricole lui-même
le premier usage intéressant pour le
biogaz
c'est de remplacer le fioul de la
mécanisation agricole par du biogaz on
sait faire aujourd'hui les gros moteurs
à gaz deuxième usage qui peut être
intéressant alors là c'est toujours en
circuit court entre guillemets c'est
tout ce qui est transports en commun et
transport de marchandises
pas très loin de là au biogaz a été fait
donc ça peut être les dessertes
scolaires les camionnettes de livraison
etc
par contre toujours pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur on utilise aujourd'hui
en france de l'ordre de 500 un peu moins
450 milliards de kilowattheures de gaz
fossile
si avec le biogaz
on arrive dans 450 milliards de gaz
fossile ci avec le biogaz on arrive à 50
milliards
ça sera déjà vachement beau donc on peut
pas imaginer faire du biogaz pour
remplacer le gaz de toutes les
chaudières à gaz qu'on a aujourd'hui ça
malheureusement ça passera pas je suis
en même temps donc
alors encore une question sur les
productions d'énergie donc sur le
nucléaire
question suivante est la question est la
suivante donc le nucléaire pour vous et
il était la meilleure solution est aussi
dans la prise en compte du coût carbone
du nucléaire est ce que vous prenez en
compte tous les coûts annexes notamment
liée au démantèlement au stockage et au
traitement des déchets etc etc
d'accord alors c'est une réponse
technique et une réponse plus sociétale
sur la rive sur la question technique
est ce qu'on prend tout en compte quand
on fait le coût carbone nucléaire la
réponse est oui et alors la raison pour
laquelle on arrive à des petits chiffres
pour le nucléaire tient la nature
humaine de l'énergie exactement comme
tout à l'heure j'ai comparé le vent et
le pétrole en montrant qu'ils avaient
une question de densité et ben je
verrais appliquer ce raisonnement au
nucléaire l'énergie nucléaire est une
énergie considérablement plus dense que
l' énergie de la combustion donc l'
énergie de la combustion c'est de
l'énergie chimique
l'énergie nucléaire est laid des
millions de fois plus dense en fils yo
nan un gramme d'uranium vous libérer
autant d'énergie qu'en brûlant une tonne
de pétrole ce qui veut dire que
l'énergie nucléaire met en jeu des
toutes petites quantités de matière pour
produire des grandes quantités d'énergie
alors c'est justement parce que vous
avez beaucoup d'énergie dans un petit
volume que il faut c'est bien son
protégé donc que vous mettez du béton
puis encore du béton puis encore du
béton puis encore du béton justement à
ça que c'est ça l'origine un peu plus
que quand vous avez un moteur de voiture
mais par contre l' avantage c'est que
derrière vous manipuler des petites
quantités de matière pour avoir des
grandes quantités d'énergie
or le co2 du cycle il est lié à la
quantité de matières qu'on manipule la
quantité de minerai qu'il faut aller
chercher la quantité d'acier de béton
qui font couler pour faire le réacteur
et c'est donc vous allez à faire en fait
par rapport à la quantité d'énergie
libérée manipuler des petites quantités
de matières donc émettre
proportionnellement à l'énergie produite
des petites quantités de co2 c'est de là
que vient le contenu carbone est par
contre l'énergie nucléaire elle-même ne
fait pas de co2 casser un noyau
d'uranium en deux c'est pas comme oxydé
un atome de carbone
ça fait pas de co2 donc le co2 annexes
j'ai envie de dire comme il est rapporté
à des quantités de matières qu'on
manipule qui sont beaucoup beaucoup plus
faible que avec d'autres formes
d'énergie du coup vous avez un contenu
carbone qui est très bas
c'est ça qui explique même en tenant
compte du démantèlement de
l'enrichissement de enfin de ski à
l'amont à l'aval
alors après ce que le nucléaire est la
solution
si la question c'est est-ce que le
nucléaire est la solution et que je
complète en pour conserver le niveau de
vie que nous avons aujourd'hui sans
combustibles fossiles dans le monde la
réponse est non bonne nouvelle même le
nucléaire suffira pas parce que il est
trop bas aujourd'hui il devrait se
déployer trop vite pour remplacer tous
les combustibles fossiles dans trente ou
quarante ans ça passe pas par contre
plus on en fait plus l'effort de
sobriété qu'on va devoir faire alors
c'est quoi la sobriété s'est passé de la
voiture au vélo électrique c'est passé
de 40 mètres carrés habitables par
personne à 30 c est ca c'est manger
moins de viande c'est ça la sobriété un
essai avoir moins d'objets
de tout et n'importe quoi qui
s'entassent dans la cave ou dans la
corbeille de l'entrée d'akon de gad
elmaleh parce que ça peut toujours
servir un jour jamais et bien la
sobriété c'est ça d'un plus on fera de
nucléaire - ont frappé fort sur la
sobriété mais on en fera quand même donc
la manière que j'ai de présenter le
nucléaire comme la solution en fait
c'est un élément de solution qui permet
de nous elle léger l'effort et de nous
là léger plus efficacement que les
énergies diffuse tout simplement parce
que ces concentrés et pilotable donc là
on renvoie à la physique
indépendamment de tous les débats sur
les coups qu'on pourrait on pas y passer
la nuit
et bien en fait le nucléaire est en
pilotable et manipulant des petites
quantités de matière il est physiquement
intrinsèquement supérieur aux énergies
qui sont diffusées non pilotable ce qui
veut dire que si on fait du nucléaire on
a un effort important sur la sobriété
mais si on en fait pas on a un effort
considérable
c'est un peu comme ça qu'il faut faire
les choses et c'est ça qui explique que
je suis à la fois pour toutes en disant
mais c'est pas du tout suffisant pour
nous exonérer d'efforts absolument
considérable à faire sur le risque alors
du coup est ce que le futur l'avenir ce
serait pas d'avoir un mix énergétique le
plus large possible et non pas tout
concentrer sur un ou deux types
d'énergie seulement alors la
diversification est quelque chose qui
paraît être un argument de bon sens
c'est évident on vous dit votre médecin
par exemple vous dis il faut vous y ait
une alimentation diversifiée en fait on
confond souvent de choses qui sont
diversifiés et équilibrés mais il ya des
diversifications qui sont pas du tout
pertinente alors une blague que je fais
souvent je suis désolé si ça concerne de
la famille de quelqu'un dans
l'assistance et de dire si je vous coupe
une de vos deux jambes pour la remplacer
par une jambe de bois
j'ai diversifié aux appuis corps avant
vous aviez deux jambes identique après
vous avez deux gendres différentes
d'accord avec moi j'ai diversifié aux
appuis bon je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
beaucoup de gens dans la salle qui vont
considérer que j'ai amélioré leur
situation
donc la diversification c'est pas un
argument d'autorité pour que ça devienne
mieux au sens du régime alimentaire
équilibré
il faut que ce avec quoi vous
diversifiez soit mieux que ce que ça
remplace
mais si c'est pas mieux que ce que ça
remplace vous n'êtes pas diversifié vous
est affaibli donc la frontière entre la
diversification et l'affaiblissement le
fameux mix bon bah ça dépend avec quoi
vous remplacez je vais vous donner un
autre exemple vous ne mettez que de la
nourriture dans votre bouche pour manger
je sais pas bien faut diversifier
bettevy aussi des cailloux ou de l'acide
chlorhydrique donc la diversification
oui à condition que ce soit avec mieux
que ce que ça remplace si c'est avec
moins bien que ce que ça remplace
je le redis ça non seulement ça ne vous
avait pas de bénéfice mais ça vous a
fait d'accord alors du coup encore deux
questions sur les énergies apprend au
passé sur un autre thème l'hydrogène on
en parle beaucoup en ce moment notamment
pour une possible future energy dans les
transports en grosse partie ou dans les
procédés industriels qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
alors l'hydrogène n'est pas une source
d'énergie disponible dans la nature il
ya quelque chose que j'ai pas eu le
temps de dire ce soir mais que je vais
vous rappeler donc je vais revenir à la
physique aux heures en physique
il ya une loi qui est extrêmement bien
connu qui est un des lois cardinal de la
physique qui s'appelle la loi de
conservation de l'énergie
la loi de conservation de l'énergie vous
dis un truc qui est tout bête elle vous
dit dans un système qui éclot qui ne
communiquent pas avec l'extérieur
la quantité d'énergie que vous avez est
rigoureusement constante au cours du
temps
c'est très simple comme loin grâce
concerne je suis comme une boîte de
conserve à l'intérieur d'un système clos
l'énergie ce concert alors pourquoi est
ce que c'est important pour arriver à
l'hydrogène
tout simplement parce que à ce moment si
vous regardez l'humanité pris comme un
système est bien pour disposer d'énergie
l'humanité doit communiquer avec
l'extérieur lena l'humanité ne peut pas
créer d'énergie en son sein sans
communiquer avec l'extérieur donc toutes
les énergies qu'on peut utiliser
elles doivent déjà être à l'extérieur
donc l'énergie pour les hommes et les
femmes
ça veut dire quelque chose qui existe
déjà dans l'environnement et qu'on peut
exploiter à notre profit alors
correspondent à cette définition
le charbon qui brûle tout seul le gaz
qui brûle tout seul le pétrole qui brûle
tout seul les chutes d'eau qui
tout seul de l'énergie le vent qui
soufflait tout seul le rayonnement
solaire qui fournit tout seul de
l'énergie les noyaux d'uranium qui se
casse en deux qui etc
mais il n'y a pas l'hydrogène là dedans
il n'ya pas sur terre d'endroits où il
ya un réservoir d'hydrogène en voyant
des quelques sources mais enfin ils sont
ridicules mais fallait un peu petite
angèle natif mais c'est tout petit sinon
y'a pas de réservoir d'hydrogène donc
l'hydrogène faut le faire c'est comme
l'électricité
tant que vous n'aurez pas trouvé le
moyen de brancher les cafetières sur les
éclairs d'orage l'électricité c'est pas
une source que vous trouvez dans la
nature faut la faire je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure comment les bains
l'hydrogène c'est pareil il y en a plein
dans la nature c'est le premier
constituant l'univers
il y en a plein sur terre c'est le
constituant principal de l'eau mais il
n'est pas disponible sous forme
d'énergie donc pour l'avoir sous forme
d'hydrogène pur faut le séparer des
autres atomes auquel il est associé et
en particulier de l'atome d'oxygène dans
l'eau ou du carbone dans le méthane est
donc aujourd'hui de l'hydrogène on sait
très bien en faire ça consomme plein
d'énergie et en fait on en fait avec en
extrayant à la fois de l'eau et du
méthane gaz naturel en mélangeant les
deux donc on met du méthane et de l'eau
ensemble et on chauffe très fort et du
coup l'ensemble des deux serait arrangé
vous faites l'hydrogène et du co2 faire
une tonne d'hydrogène aujourd'hui ses
dix tonnes de co2 avec ce processus si
vous le faites avec la gazéification du
charbon est également une possibilité
trente tonnes de co2 par tonne
d'hydrogène donc pour que l'hydrogène
devienne un vecteur intéressant dans une
décarbonation de l'économie il faut le
produire sans émettre de co2 je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails techniques
le truc qui parce qu'il ya plusieurs
manières de faire mais la manière que
tout le monde a en tête celle
électrolyse de l'eau mais à ce moment il
faut que l'électricité de départ soit
décarbonée parce que si vous électrolyse
et l'hydrogène avec de l'électricité
fait au charbon et au gaz et par exemple
si vous faites de l'hydrogène avec le
mix énergétique enfin le mix électrique
parlons paillage éthique le mix
électrique allemand moyens actuels votre
voiture à hydrogène elle vous émet deux
fois plus de co2 que votre voiture à
essence donc il faut bien le faire
l'hydrogène peut pas mal le faire
question qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
comme hydrogène avec de l'électro lise
alors je vais vous donner un exemple si
vous voulez remplacer le pétrole des
transports de marchandises ont poids
lourds en france par de l'hydrogène
il faut augmenter la production
française d'électricité de 20 %
donc en gros il vous faut dix à douze
réacteurs nucléaires actuelles de plus
on peut le faire
vous avez passé hier comme ça pour les
avions à hydrogène c'est pareil c'est la
même quantité qu'il faudrait deux
réacteurs en plus si on voulait faire
voler à l'hydrogène les avions qui
quitte le sol français en ce moment
enfin avant que vide donc pardon faut
faire avec du coup vite surtout c'est
plus efficace eu
et si on fait avec des éoliennes et du
solaire c'est encore pire et surtout
c'est beaucoup plus carbonées puisque le
panneau solaire il est à 50 grammes de
co2 par kilowattheure donc le
kilowattheure des trogen derrière par
électrolyse ils étaient 100 grammes de
co2 enfin en gros quand vous regardez
vous vous rendez compte que l'hydrogène
en fait il ya deux applications où c'est
intéressant et pour le reste en
particulier dans les transports
ça ira beaucoup plus vite passé les gens
aux vélos électriques que et rend sur
des pistes cyclables que d'essayer de
mettre toutes les voitures à hydrogène
est beaucoup plus vite le hydrogène il
ya deux applications que ça peut être
intéressant c'est pour faire des engrais
parce que même si on aime l'agriculture
douce et cetera ce qui est mon cas on va
encore avoir besoin d'engrais pendant un
petit moment et la chimie des engrais
démarre avec la synthèse de l'ammoniac
et ça ça démarre avec la production
d'hydrogène
c'est à ça que sert 40% de l'hydrogène
produit dans le monde et la deuxième
chose qui est intéressante avec de
l'hydrogène c'est de fer de l'acier sans
co2 aujourd'hui l'acier effet en
mélangeant du minerai de fer c'est à
dire un oxyde de fer avec du charbon
très particulier du charbon
métallurgique et le charbon vous enlève
l'oxygène de l'oxydé de fer et voulait
se faire comme ça que ça marche et bat
pour enlever l'oxygène de l'oxydé de fer
on peut aussi utiliser l'hydrogène
les suédois ont mis 40 milliards sur la
table pour démarrer un projet comme ça
donc le deuxième truc intéressant avec
des affaires avec de l'hydrogène
décarbonés c'est de l'acier décarbonés
et je vous ai dit tout à l'heure de
l'acier y en a absolument partout dans
nos vies c'est aussi indispensable que
le pétrole pour le mode de vie que nous
avons aujourd'hui
donc les deux ans les deux applications
intéressantes de l'hydrogène pour moi
c'est des applications industrielles
c'est l'acier et les engrais donc on
commence déjà par s'occuper de ça et si
éventuellement il reste une tonnes
d'hydrogène
on fera un dirigeable non je plaisante
on fera un avion à hydrogène mais c'est
pas ça qui va sauver le transport aérien
alors une dernière question sur la
partie production d'énergie il ya
d'autres questions qui sont venues entre
temps mais on pourra peut-être revenir
dans un second temps la biomasse et quel
point c'est ce qu'on peut lui accorder
quelles sont ces possibilités de
croissance alors la biomasse est une des
manières d'utiliser le sol en passant
aux énergies fossiles
quelque chose de très remarquable qui
s'est produit c'est qu'on n'a plus
besoin de l'espace pour notre production
énergétique puisque tous venaient du
sous sol
avant on avait besoin du sol on avait
besoin de l'herbe pour nourrir les
animaux de trait c'était de l'énergie et
après on n'a plus besoin de l'herbe pour
nourrir les animaux de trait et parce
que savez on avait besoin du bois pour
se chauffer et pour alimenter les forges
du reste on en avait tellement besoin
que la france était en pleine
déforestation jusqu'en 1850
c'est le charbon qui a sauvé les forêts
françaises aussi étonnant que cela
puisse paraître
et une fois qu'on a eu le charbon ne
plus le besoin des arbres
donc on les a laissés pousser donc le
sol on l'a eu entièrement pour nos
activités alimentaires récréatives et
les infrastructures depuis qu'on a les
combustibles fossiles
quand on veut repasser aux énergies
renouvelables
on a de nouveau besoin du sol on a de
nouveau besoin du sol notamment pour
l'énergie qui va remplacer les
combustibles fossiles alors c'est la
biomasse 1 où ça peut être de la surface
occupée par des panneaux solaires peu
importe on a besoin du sol pour le
matériau plastique on veut plus d'acier
alors on va utiliser du bois pour ça il
faut du sol on veut plus de plastique
pour s'habiller on veut des fibres
textiles mais pour ça
végétal france info du sol donc en fait
on va se retrouver avec une concurrence
des usages du sol et enfin on a besoin
du sol pour les activités du pays c'est
à dire laisser vivre les petites bêtes
la biodiversité
donc en fait le sol il est l'objet d'un
nombre d' usage concurrentielle entre
lesquels il faut arbitrer donc la bonne
question c'est dans cet arbitrage ou est
ce qu'on veut la biomasse est ce que on
laisse la forêt pousser et faire un
puits de carbone et on se chauffe au gaz
ou est ce qu on se chauffe au bois en
laissant pas la forêt pousser et bien la
réponse à cette question c'est qu'en
fait on peut utiliser au mieux ou plus
plus exactement le surplus qui arrive
dans une dans un écosystème matures donc
en gros temps que l'écosystème est en
croissance
faut le laisser pousser et une fois
qu'il est mature on peut utiliser le la
production supplémentaire excédentaire
de cet écosystème qui sinon mouret se
décomposera etc
donc quand vous regardez ce que ça
représente en france ça représente pas
très loin dans ce qu'on utilise déjà on
pourrait pas en utiliser
considérablement plus et donc le la
biomasse est une bonne idée pour le
chauffage en mai en milieu rural et le
biogaz dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
est aussi un usage pertinent de la
biomasse mais tout ça doit se faire dans
des limites qui sont les limites de la
non atteinte à la capacité à la hausse
tout de biomasse qu'on a dans le pays
parce que si on diminue le stock de
biomasse à ce moment c'est de la
déforestation ça contribue aux émissions
juste pour rebondir du coup sur cette
dernière question de sur la biomasse
notamment sur le biogaz est ce que le
biogaz n'a pas un risque de concurrence
avec l'agriculture conventionnelle et
enfin les riques dur tout court et
est-ce qu'on n'a pas un risque
d'appauvrissement des sols à long terme
alors il ya beaucoup de questions là
aussi là dedans qui sont dessus mais ça
mélange à la fois les pratiques
agricoles et le produit les cultures
donc le produit des cultures je viens de
répondre si bien sûr il ya un risque de
concurrence puisque encore une fois le
sol on peut pas l'utiliser
c'est comme l'histoire de la crémière
on peut pas l'utiliser pour plusieurs
choses à la fois donc si on l'utilisé
pour se nourrir on n'utilise pas pour la
biomasse énergétique si on les utilise
pour faire des fibres textiles ont
l'utilisent pas pour la biomasse
énergétique ni pour se nourrir et c'est
donc on a un arbitrage à faire un entre
tous ces usages donc sk pas un risque de
concurrence si il ya de fait un risque
de concurrence
après est-ce que les pratiques est-ce
que tel usage favorise telle dégradation
du sol ces terres est ce que le sol se
dégrade plus vite si on fait des plantes
énergétiques que si on fait des plantes
alimentaires là la réponse est non c'est
la pratique agricole elle même qui
détermine ce qui va se passer avec le
sol ok il me semble qu'on avait des
questions aussi sur les conséquences du
changement climatique on change un peu
de thématiques voilà pour venir sur
notre thématique du coup je pense que
pas mal de personnes ont réagi par
rapport à votre dernière des positive
est ce qu on vous en avait pas parlé
mais quid de l'emballement climatique
ce qu'on appelle l'emballement
climatique alors ce qu'on appelle
l'emballement climatique c'est la
possibilité qu'un certain nombre de
premières conséquences du réchauffement
climatique contribue à accélérer le
processus
en relâchant plus de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère
alors ces emballements il y en a
plusieurs qui que je vais décrire le
premier c'est le dépérissement des
écosystèmes
par exemple si les forêts se mettent à
brûler de plus en plus souvent une forêt
qui brûle c'est du co2 qui repart dans
l'air et par ailleurs c'est un
écosystème affaibli derrière pour
repomper du co2 en provenance de
l'atmosphère
ça c'est un phénomène d'emballement un
deuxième phénomène d'emballement alors
plus local celui ci si la fonte de la
banquise
quand la banquise fond vous avez une
surface très réfléchissante la glace qui
est remplacée par une surface très
absorbante qui est l'eau océanique et à
ce moment l'océan se met à se réchauffer
plus vite puisqu'il absorbe plus
d'énergie du soleil
autre exemple d'emballement vous avez
dans les régions du nord enfin plus
exactement près des pôles mais c'est
surtout les régions du nord près du pôle
nord puisque au sud ces traits océanique
enfin le pôle sud est très ancienne vous
avez du sol gelé en permanence qu'on
appelle du pergélisol ou du permafrost
dans lequel vous avez du carbone qui est
contenue ce carbone peut être contenu
soit sous forme de carbone pur soit sous
forme de méthane et quand le sol dégel
ce qui lui était pas arrivé depuis des
millions d'années et bien à ce moment il
relâche le carbone qu'il contient et ça
contre il a fait une source
additionnelle d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans l'atmosphère voilà des
phénomènes d'emballement alors la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que la science
comme on est en train de faire une
expérience pour la première fois la
science connaît mal les seuils qui
s'applique à tous ces phénomènes
on les connaît pas tous autant que vous
êtes vous avez fait des expériences pour
la première fois dans votre vie par
exemple vous mariez qui dans cette salle
s'étant mariée a eu très exactement sur
les vingt ans qui ont suivi ce qu'il
s'imaginait qu'il ou elle aurait bon à
peu près personne
donc quand vous faites une expérience
pour la première fois vous avez toujours
des surprises
ça fait partie de la règle du jeu donc
en ce qui concerne ces phénomènes
d'emballement on aura nécessairement des
surprises bonnes ou mauvaises pour le
moment on en a plutôt des mauvaises
c'est à dire que quand vous regardez la
production scientifique de ces dernières
années pour à peu près tous les
phénomènes qui sont regardés d'à peu
près les conséquences ont tendance à
aller plus vite et à se rapprocher plus
vite des seuils que l'idée qu'on sentait
ya quelques années et donc la question
sous jacente évidemment et la crainte
qu'à un moment le truc échappe à tout
contrôle et que quoi qu'on fasse de
toute façon eh bien on va vers
l'état l'état guerrier dont je parlais
tout à l'heure
évidemment un peu désagréable la science
aujourd'hui n'a pas la réponse c'est à
dire qu'il ya un certain nombre de
conséquences qui sont qualitativement
identifié mais les seuils précis brrr
difficile
je vais vous donner un exemple au
dernier le dernier rapport du giec
parlait d'une élévation possible au
niveau du niveau de la mer à l'horizon
de quelques siècles qui était de 2 ou 3
mètres dans le prochain rapport du
siècle dans le scénario s'est montée à
16 et la raison c'est l'accélération de
la fonte du groenland et les craintes
sur la désintégration de l'antarctique
de l'ouest qui sont apparus dans la
littérature scientifique ces dernières
années et dont évidemment la presse
grand public vous parle quand ils ont
fini de vous parler de la composition de
l'équipe de france donc le qui est aussi
un sujet important mais donc le
voilà donc ces processus d'emballement
j'ai envie de dire malheureusement on en
découvre un peu tous les jours parce que
ils sont difficiles à évaluer
longtemps à l'avancé mais il y en aura
alors je pense qu'il avait effleuré dans
votre discours et je l'ouvré rebondir
dessus je pense assez facilement c'est
quelles sont les conséquences du
réchauffement sur la ressource en eau la
disponibilité en 10 alors sur la
ressource en eau le réchauffement
climatique en france va globalement
conduire un assèchement des sols
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le cadre
d'un climat qui se réchauffe vous avez
plusieurs choses qui se mettent à passer
en simultanément
la première c'est qu'un climat plus
chaud favorise l'évaporation partout où
il ya de l'eau et en particulier au
dessus des océans donc un climat plus
chaud favorise l'évaporation en
provenance des océans donc globalement
il va y avoir plus de précipitation
parce qu'une fois que la vapeur d'eau
est rentrée dans l'atmosphère et
condensée elle pleut et la question
c'est est-ce que ça va pleuvoir partout
de la même manière
ou pas et là la réponse est non et en
particulier tout le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen et la france est un tout
petit peu concernée va voir plutôt un
déficit de précipitations c'est à dire
que le surplus de pluie ça concernera
les autres mais pas d'eau ensuite la
pluie peut très bien être plus abondante
dans l'année mais plus mal répartie vous
vous rappelez de l'épisode de
précipitations intenses qui a eu lieu
dans le sud de la france ya pas très
longtemps là où les inondations ont eu
lieu ils ont pris localement 800 mm de
pluie en 24 48 heures 800 mm c'est les
précipitations annuelles normal ici
d'accord en 24 heures
donc vous avez un épisode et demi comme
ça dans l'année puis plus rien le reste
de l'année
oui vous avez plus de précipitations que
d'habitude enfin ça fait pas vraiment
vos affaires et en fait ce qui compte
vraiment en ce qui concerne la facilité
qu'ont les plantes à pousser
c'est certes ce qu'il pleut mais surtout
ce que le sol va en garder donc en fait
ce qui compte c'est l'humidité des sols
et ce qui est vraiment intéressant pour
savoir si demain l'agriculture et les
écosystèmes se porteront bien c est ce
que les soldes vont être globalement
plus secs ou globalement plus humide et
là en france
la réponse c'est qu'ils vont être
devenir globalement plus sec parce que
même s'il pleut un peu plus
évaporation des soldes a aussi fortement
augmenté et il suffit que ces
précipitations soient plus mal réparti
ce qui est aussi une tendance à venir
dans le cadre du réchauffement
climatique que je devrais plutôt appeler
la dérive climatique pour que du coup
les sols s'assèche donc la finale à la
part dont le la sécheresse agricole et
la sécheresse des sols vont
statistiquement augmenter à l'avenir
en france une dernière question sur ses
conséquences on parle aussi notamment du
gulf stream et du ralentissement du gulf
stream un courant qui est censé nous
apporter de la chaleur
comment est-ce que ça intervient dans
tout ça alors le gulf stream
en fait c'est une expression qui est un
peu un propre le vrai gulf stream
il désigne un courant qui comme son nom
l'indiqué dans le golfe gulf stream
le courant du golfe donc en fait le gulf
stream c'est une boucle qui ne quitte
pas l'équateur ce qui nous réchauffe en
europe ça s'appelle la dérive nord
atlantique et c'est un embranchement du
gulf stream qui remonte et qui va
jusqu'au sud du groenland où la halle au
sommet a plongé alors les raisons pour
lesquelles ça se passe comme ça je vais
pas les détails et ce soir sinon je vais
vous assommer par contre ce qui est
important c'est que le moteur de cette
dérive nord atlantique
c'est notamment la plongée des eaux que
vous avez au sud du groenland qui sert
de pompes aspirantes quand les eaux
plonge vous aspire l'eau qui est à côté
alors la raison pour laquelle les au
plongeon c'est à cause de leur
température de la formation de la
banquise leur densité dans un climat qui
se réchauffe
un des trucs qui pourrait se passer
c'est une augmentation des
précipitations sur l'océan lui même et à
ce moment un adoucissement de l'eau la
salinité diminue et à ce moment-là
densité de l'eau diminué elle plonge -
facilement et vous avez également un
effet qui est dû au moins la moindre
formation de la banquise est alors si la
plongée des eaux se ralentit à ce moment
là dérive nord atlantique se ralentit et
en fait il ya eu des époques dans le
passé où cette plongée des eaux s'est
brutalement interrompue à la un mode off
un interrupteur et à ce moment vous avez
une modification traces tic du climat
régional en europe qui s'opèrent en
quelques décennies
alors si ce processus arrivé à l'avenir
dans un contexte de réchauffement global
là pour le coup les modélisateurs son
ont pas de fin beaucoup vous dise la
température en europe peut-être mois en
moyenne pour autant n'évoluera pas à la
baisse par rapport à aujourd'hui
d'aucuns vous disent mais on se
rapprochera d'un climat continental
donc en fait avec des contrats sont tous
les saisons beaucoup plus marqué et
c'est en fait peut-être que ce sera
beaucoup plus sec enfin c'est un peu la
bouteille alors en fait on sait pas trop
ce qui se passe si jamais cette dérive
nord atlantique s'interrompt à l'avenir
pour le moment il n'est pas prévu
qu'elle s'interrompent dans le siècle à
venir mais à l'échelle de quelques
siècles
c'est un point d'interrogation
supplémentaires ok alors on a dressé un
certain nombre de constats se soit
retiré un certain nombre d' alerte au
niveau mondial national
une des questions à mon avis qui arrive
souvent aussi c'est comment on passe à
l'action locale
comment on peut être territoire bas
carbone par où il faut commencer
alors il faut commencer par mesure est
un des problèmes que vous allez avoir
c'est que la décentralisation du pouvoir
n'est pas allée avec la décentralisation
de l' expertise et donc une difficulté
qu'il y a dans la gestion locale c'est
d'arriver à avoir toute l'information
qui va du global au local pour savoir où
est-ce qu'on a des marges de manoeuvre
et où est-ce qu'on est dans la barque
commune est en fête
on peut revendiquer des choses mais en
fait ça restera des slogans parce qu'on
n'a pas les on n'a pas les leviers de
l'action un point important de mon point
de vue c'est qu'il faut pas opposer le
local et national
parce que si on décide de commencer à
dire c'est à toi à moi etc
on va pas s'en sortir donc il faut qu'on
essaye de ramer tous dans le même sens
le ski est à la main du local on va dire
dans l'ensemble ce qu'il faut faire
alors j'ai commencé par dire ce qu'il
faut faire si on veut être sérieux sur
la question climatique
il faut qu'on agisse sur les émissions
qui sont associés à notre mode de vie
vous avez c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'empreinte carbone vous avez quatre
gros paquet dans ses émissions
vous avez ce qu'on mange vous avez ce
qu'on achète vous avez là où on vit donc
les émissions associées au logement et
vous avez la façon de se déplacer
voilà en gros les quatre gros paquet et
vous avez un cinquième petit paquet qui
sont les services publics qui dépendent
voilà si vous êtes malade et vous allez
à l'hôpital et si vous avez des enfants
qui vont à l'école et c'est assez des
émissions dont vous bénéficiez aussi
parce que les écoles faut les construire
les chauffer l'hôpital info le
construire le show fait fabriquer les
médicaments les scanners et faire venir
les infirmières donc tout ça a fait que
ça fait des émissions le sur
l'alimentation le premier déterminant de
l'empreinte carbone c'est la part de
viande qu'on mange et en particulier de
viande rouge donc là dedans bas il faut
voir ce qui peut revenir au local un
truc qui peut être pertinent c'est
d'essayer de se mettre d'accord entre
acteurs locaux pour avoir des pratiques
d'élevage qui conduisent à faire moins
d'animaux de meilleure qualité
acheter plus cher ou pas que l'éleveur
se suicide et valoriser ça au travers de
circuits plus courts faisant en sorte
que les marges de distribution sont
moins élevés et du coup les autres
acteurs de la chaîne certeau a
évidemment le distributeur hyper tout le
monde peut pas gagner dans cette
histoire
mais en gros l'équation vous l'avez là
en ce qui concerne l' acheter
alors ça c'est pas du tout à la main du
territoire c'est pas vous qui allez
demain matin fabriquer vos chaussures
votre robe
le micro que vous tenez à la main la
voiture dans laquelle vous êtes venus
ici et c'est pas bien ni le vélo du
reste donc même si c'est pourquoi donc
le territoire là dessus qu'est ce qu'il
a comme main j'ai envie de dire
il peut avoir de favoriser le
remplacement sur son sol d'activité de
l'ancien monde entre guillemets par des
activités du nouveau monde donc si vous
avez un fabricant de portière de voiture
et vous arrivez à le convaincre de faire
des dérailleurs de vélo c'est pas c'est
pas plus mal
mais sinon c'est essentiellement inciter
les gens à essayer d'avoir moins envie
de trucs et de machins pour passer le
temps il ya évidemment quelque chose qui
alors là dans la main des élus qui est
la question des locaux dédiés aux
commerces tout petit sujet mais l'action
elle se passe là aussi en ce qui
concerne le troisième point qui est le
logement
là ce que peut faire le territoire c'est
favoriser l'amélioration de leur
performance thermique est en fait
carbonique et donc ça peut concerner à
la fois la montée en compétence des
filières professionnelles parce que
c'est un énorme le sujet la montée en
compétence des filières professionnelles
ça peut concerner de l'artisanat de
fabrication de matériaux d'appareils de
chauffage etc
et évidemment l'incitation
des habitants du territoire améliorer la
performance carbonique de leur logement
et c'est vrai également pour le
tertiaire et enfin en ce qui concerne le
quatrième morceau qui est se déplacer là
c'est pareil le territoire c'est pas lui
qui va fabriquer les véhicules
par contre il peut inciter à des usages
différenciés
donc il peut s'occuper des transports en
commun il peut s'occuper des
infrastructures pour le vélo et il peut
s'occuper il ya et moi mon observation
c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui est en
train de beaucoup changé la pratique
dans le vélo qui est le vélo électrique
parce que l'électrification fait qu'il
ya plein de gens qui ont pas peur de
monter sur un vélo même s'ils n'ont pas
fait de sport depuis 45 ans et demi
alors qu'avec le vélo mécanique il ya
cette peur et après par ailleurs il ya
un vrai un vrai sujet sur le vélo qui
hélas non cohabitation avec d'autres
usagers qui sont dangereux pour lui
alors il y en a deux il ya ceux qui sont
plus lourds et plus gros c'est les
voitures mais il y en a aussi un autre
qui est ce qu'ils sont plus légers et
moins rapide sans les piétons les voies
mixtes cyclistes piétons
c'est très dangereux parce que le piéton
on pense qu'il est chez lui donc il fait
pas gaffe à la wii va et ils circulent
en regardant son smartphone et en
laissant ses gosses
jouer le cycliste pense qu'il est chez
lui et il dit je vais quand même pas
aller à la vitesse d'un piéton sinon ça
sert à rien que j'avais l'eau et donc
c'est des endroits qui sont pas si
rassurant que ça évidemment l'autre
c'est là c'est là c'est la voiture est
donc là le territoire peut agir aussi
sur les infrastructures
et puisqu'un des partenaires préférés du
territoire c'est le btp on peut très
bien leur demander de faire des pistes
cyclables
plutôt que de faire des ronds points
donc le de piste vélo travail ah oui oui
dépit du quotidien oui oui bien sûr
maintenant quand il ya moins de
touristes japonais venant en avion ça
sera pas mal aussi d'avoir des pistes
cyclables longues distances pour faire
venir les parisiens en vélo et leur
offrir le gîte et le couvert une fois
qu'ils sont arrivés jusque chez vous oui
mais ça reviendra
voilà donc voilà en gros ce sur quoi le
territoire à la main sur quoi il n'a pas
la main il n'a pas la main sur la
production des voitures et encore moins
sur leur normalisation il n'a pas la
main sur les obligations réglementaires
qui sont du ressort de l'état il n'a pas
la main sur la fiscalité il apparaît
donc il faut à la fois qui s'empare de
ce sur quoi il peut avoir la main sans
attendre que les autres le fassent et ne
pas tenir un discours qui à mon avis est
contre-productif qui est de dire il ya
que chez moi qui se passe des choses
intelligentes l'état quand même quelle
bande d'ados ils ont rien compris même
si c'est vrai parfois et
essayer de convaincre justement
aux sphères dans la sphère nationale
qu'il faut que tout ça se fasse de
manière coordonnée
je retiens la dimension formation donc
ce soir on est tous en formation en
direct je retiens l'alimentation et le
pays porte un projet alimentaire
territoriale j'en profite parce que noël
tellier notre élu référent est présent
ce soir et le pays portent aussi une
plate-forme territoriale de rénovation
énergétique qui souhaitent accompagner
tous les habitants du territoire dans la
rénovation de leur logement
donc voilà c'est pas parfait mais on
fait notre part une nouvelle question
peut-être olivier oui bon on a public
est mal un jeu majoritairement composée
d'élus dont il ya plusieurs questions
qui reviennent sur cet aspect vraiment
très concret est-ce que vous avez
d'autres exemples que d'actions que les
élus peuvent mettre en place notamment
les élus des petites communes
je redis je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
d'absolument essentiel qui est de
commencer par comprendre
alors aujourd'hui il ya des outils qui
aident à comprendre et je vais reparler
de l'expérience il ya d'autres qui me
paraissent importants je vais reparler
de l'expérience à laquelle a participé
belhani qu'est la convention citoyenne
pour le climat qui me semble avoir
montré l'effet de levier du à deux
éléments qui sont essentielles qui sont
la formation et le fait d'agir de
manière concertée donc de se parler haut
et le dans les petites communes il
semble que c'est les deux premières
marches de l'escalier quoi qu'on fasse
derrière donc ce qu'il faut essayer de
faire c'est d'attirer l'intérêt d'une
partie aussi importante que possible de
la population sur ces sujets là juste
leur dire
on va essayer de comprendre de quoi il
parle et de quoi il retourne et donc il
me semble que la bonne manière de
commencer surtout dans les petites
communes où tout le monde se connaît ces
salles avantages des tic commune c'est
que en gros c'est quelques salles de
classe ou un lycée donc c'est pas trés
c'est pas très compliqué d'avoir tout le
monde qui se connaît et la bonne manière
de créer de la confiance ou de ou de
travailler avec des gens qu'on connaît
déjà
c'est de partir de la définition du
problème donc je pense que dans les
petites communes c'est vraiment le
premier truc à faire avant de savoir si
on va faire un
un jardin partagé un potager pas quoi
c'est vraiment d'essayer de parts et de
partir d'un constat commun donc là il ya
des outils qui existent aujourd'hui pour
ça par exemple il ya un jeu qui
s'appelle la fresque du climat qui est
un truc très low tech
ça se joue avec une grande feuille de
papier et un jeu trescartes vraiment de
trucs pas pas compliqué du tout et bien
même dans une petite commune on peut
faire ça et on apprend soi même sur une
gestion ça dure quelques heures c'est un
jeu collectif des gens joue par équipe
il ne s'oppose pas c'est important et ça
permet de commencer à toucher un peu du
doigt le sujet que j'ai évoqué ce soir
il ya des outils également pour
découvrir ce que c'est que son empreinte
carbone personnel
aujourd'hui carbone khatami aux places a
mis au point par exemple un outil qui
s'appelle my ses hôtes ou alors je suis
désolé c'est en anglais mais bon qu'on
prendrait tous bons co2 et c'est un
outil qui se déploient notamment par le
biais d' ambassadeur
donc des gens qui peuvent faire des
conférences on aurait de fribourg une
somme tout à fait symbolique et ça c'est
également quelque chose qui peut prendre
place dans une petite commune donc un
diptyque par lequel n'importe quelle
petite commune peut commencer c'est une
fresque du climat est derrière cette
conférence
sur l'empreinte carbone personnel et une
fois qu'on a fait ça
mon expérience c'est que les gens auront
des idées vous venez de répondre à une
autre question donc c'est formidable
j'écoute mais du coup je suis perdu donc
du coup la suivante c'est c'est une
question aussi que se posent nos élus
c'est comment agir et notamment dans la
sobriété
comment engager ces actions là tout en
restant attractifs et garder un
territoire attractif
je vais refaire la même réponse et l'ue
et vous le savez mieux que moi ça ne
peut pas se faire en opposition frontale
avec vos électeurs donc ça veut dire que
la première chose à faire c'est de leur
donner envie d'aller dans cette
direction est la meilleure manière que
je connaisse de leur donner envie c'est
de leur expliquer la situation
j'en connais pas d'autres donc je
renvoie à ce que j'ai dis juste avant il
faut qu'ils commencent par découvrir et
ensuite ils ont les idées viendront tout
seuls gens qu'on appelait à la mairie où
ils sont intéressés pour venir habiter à
souvigny et quand ils apprennent que
j'ai participé à la convention ça les
conforte dans l'idée de venir
donc c'est pas rébarbatif de de vouloir
réduire l'empreinte carbone
il ya plein de gens aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'ils cherchent et on parlait à sa
brique qui a une perte de certains ni
certaines familles d'aider les familles
30 35 ans diplômés c'est ce qu'ils
recherchent en fait s'il y avait un bas
carbone
il ya un organisme qui s'appelle l'irsn
alors c'est l'institut je crois savoir
hier l'institut sur les risques et la
sûreté nucléaire
quel rapport avec ce qui va suivre qui
sort chaque année un baromètre qui vient
de sortir là cette année où ils essayent
de comparer les perceptions des français
sur un certain nombre de problèmes
d'environnement et depuis quelques
années la question du réchauffement
climatique est en train de monter en
flèche dans les préoccupations des
français donc c'est un sondage qui a été
fait en novembre dernier donc enfin
copie d'un qui le dit et ça passait à ce
moment-là que je ne dise pas de bêtises
devant le chômage alors qu'on était en
plein qu'ovide et donc les gens savent
très bien qu'il va y avoir une
douloureuse économique derrière
devant eux il ya que le terrorisme et la
santé qui était devant mais voilà sinon
les questions d'environnement monte et
au sein des questions d'environnement le
réchauffement climatique se détache très
nettement dans les autres aujourd'hui
donc mon sentiment c'est que de parler
de ce genre de sujet fait fuir de moins
en moins de monde et à linverse dire aux
gens jouer on va on va comprendre
ensemble est une démarche qui peut être
de mieux en mieux perçue par une
fraction croissante de la population en
tout cas je pense que ça vaut le coup
d'essayer
alors deux exemples d'actions donc je
vous donnais des dents même temps les
zones à faible émission est ce que c'est
efficace alors même si c'est les zones à
faibles émissions mais même si c'est
plus aidé ya des territoires et robin et
à deuxième question dans la foulée c'est
est-ce que l'agriculture peut être un
bon vecteur pour le stockage de carbone
alors les zones à faibles émissions sauf
erreur de ma part c'est des endroits où
on essaye d'avoir des transports qui
sont on lit on limite les émissions des
véhicules c'est ça certaines
caractéristiques seulement et notamment
des grandes villes qui sont très
engorgée aux heures de pointe alors en
fait dans l'est pour traiter les
problèmes de transport la bonne question
à se poser c'est pourquoi les gens se
déplacent ça il faut partir de la
générale il ya 2 il ya deux
embranchements très différent il ya la
mobilité longue distance qui est
essentiellement une mobilité de loisirs
et il ya la mobilité du quotidien qui
est essentiellement immobile mobilité
qu'on appelle contrainte c'est à dire
qu'on part de son domicile on va au
travail faire les courses aller chercher
les gosses à l'école etc
forcément ça et là dans le domicile
travail fait la moitié alors les zones à
faibles émissions
s'il faut donner une alternative
c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment où on
dit dans cette zone là il y aura plus
tel et tel type de véhicule il faut
qu'on donne une alternative alors sa
dépendent de quoi il retourne si c'est
des camionnettes de livraison et que
l'alternative c'est que les camionnettes
de livraison passe à l'électricité ça
pose pas de problème si ces zones là
c'est des zones qui sont des zones de
destination pour des gens qui viennent
en voiture
bah il faut qu il
venir autrement ou qu'on leur propose de
poster de chez eux ou je sais pas quoi
mais en gros parce qu'au moment où on
met en oeuvre la zone c'est pas comme
d'imposer quelque chose sur le
renouvellement des voitures qui
conduirait à ce que progressivement le
parc de voitures soient de plus en plus
compatible avec ce qu'on cherche à faire
là c'est vraiment un truc du jour au
lendemain vous aviez un véhicule qui est
celui que vous avez vous aviez un une
destination qui était celle que vous
aviez et puis on vous dit hop c'est
terminé donc ça va beaucoup dépendre de
la zone est du type de véhicule qu'on
veut sortir encore une fois et de la
vitesse à laquelle on fait je je je
pense que ça peut être une brique parmi
beaucoup mais il faut regarder les
mesures concurrentes qui sont
éventuellement qui permettent d'arriver
au même résultat
il ya des il ya des mesures qui peuvent
être encore il faut arriver au même
résultat et sans dire leur nom et sans
[Musique]
pardon sens en ce sens appelé la même
manière non sans rappeler la même
manière sur la partie ce pardon si je
finis là dessus pour vous donner à
grands traits ce sur quoi on a réfléchi
aux chiffres project sur ce qu'on a
appelé les zones de moyenne densité
le cocktail qui permet d'avancer sur la
voie de la décarbonation mélange la
baisse des émissions unitaire des
voitures toujours en circulation
donc ça veut dire qu'elle consomme moins
si elle reste au pétrole qu'elle passe à
l'électricité le covoiturage
l'augmentation des transports en commun
essentiellement des bus parce que dans
les territoires de moyenne densité on
fait du bus ont fait pas du train le
vélo et ses infrastructures dédiées et
enfin ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler la
des mobilités alors tous ceux d'entre
vous qui sont restés claquemuré pendant
le coc vide se disent las des mobilités
ça va bien c'est clair que là des
mobilités sais pas je bouge plus du tout
c'est au lieu de prendre ma voiture pour
aller au travail je travaille de chez
moi mais je me prend deux heures pour
aller faire un tour à pied voilà donc c
parce que sinon on expose donc c'est ça
le met c'est une forme de des mobilités
au sens mécanique
voilà en gros le cocktail qui permet
d'avancer et enfin le dernier point
qu'il faut garder en tête c'est que les
marchandises n'ayant pas de jambes le
dernier transport mécanique devront
rester pour les marchandises au moment
où le pétrole est arrivé dans les pays
qui en ont bénéficié
ça a d'abord été utilisé pour du
transport de marchandises il ya d'abord
eu des camions avant d'avoir des
voitures et mélanie parlais tout à
l'heure des gens qui venaient à vélo se
nourrir pendant la guerre dans la sarthe
en fait il est évident que demain matin
s'il y avait plus de camions en france
les grandes villes meurt tout de faim
les grandes villes mais en toute de fin
donc vous avez un aujourd'hui un une
dépendance au pétrole dans le transport
de marchandises qui est encore plus
élevé que l'an transport de personnes
parce que tous les genres dans cette
salle qui font 20 km dans la journée si
demain matin il ya plus de voitures vous
acheter un vélo électrique vous
rejoindrez un peu mais aux 20 km vous
les ferez quand même parce que vous avez
des jambes avec les marchandises ça
marche pas donc il faut aussi prendre sa
rencontre dans l'équation qui est que la
mécanisation devra à l'avenir rester
prioritairement alloués aux marchandises
et pao et pas aux personnes après il ya
une question sur l'agriculture qui était
way est ce que la culture peut aider à
stocker du carbone parce que futur peut
aider à stocker du carbone à la réponse
est oui elle doit même le faire en fait
dans les puits de carbone c'est à dire
la manière de reprendre une partie du
carbone stocké dans l'atmosphère vous en
avez 2 vous avez les écosystèmes
forestiers ont besoin d'aller deux qui
sont vraiment sympathiques c'est des
écosystèmes forestiers et l'agriculture
hffa qui peuvent l'être l'océan c'est
pas terrible parce que quand l'océan
reprend du co2 il s'acidifient donc à
chaque fois que l'océan vous reprends du
co2 qu'on a mis dans l'air ça rend la
vie un peu plus difficile aux coraux au
plancton et à tout un tas de bestioles
qui ont besoin synthétiser du calcaire
donc il vaut beaucoup mieux que le co2
soit repris par des plantes
alors les plantes c'est quoi encore une
fois c'est les forêts l'agriculture à
l'entente l'agriculture en fait c'est
pas la plante elle-même qui va reprendre
le carbone vous faites pousser le blé le
blé vous allez le manger ou des animaux
vont le manger à ce moment
carbone qui est contenu dans le blé va
repartir dans l'atmosphère sous forme de
co2 dues à votre respiration
c'est comme ça que ça se passe vous
mangez le carbone et le carbone ressort
sous forme de respiration toute petite
partie ressort dans des matières pas
très odorante et enfin ou pas très peu
mal de rente mais l'essentiel repart
dans l'air via votre respiration donc le
co2 était dans l'air passe dans le blé
passe dans votre estomac repart dans
l'air donc celui là il est à cycle court
il contribue pas à séquestrer quoi que
ce soit celui qui contribue à séquestrer
quelque chose c'est le carbone qui
passent dans les racines du blé et dont
une petite partie reste dans le sol
parce que vous allez arrêter de labourer
le sol voilà c'est ça la séquestration
du carbone par les sols agricoles alors
ça peut se faire de cette manière ça
peut se faire en remettant des haies
dans les champs à ce moment vous avez du
carbone permanent dans la haye dans les
racines des ailes c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'agroforesterie
donc en gros les deux grandes pratiques
qui permettent de remettre du carbone
dans les sols c'est l'arrêt du labour
parce que ça arrête d'exposer le l'humus
le carbone du sol à l'oxygène de l'air
et donc de l'oxydé et de planter des
arbres partout qu'on peut donc ou de
hambach de champs ou ailleurs bien et
donc une dernière question sur les
actions quid de la mise en commun des
biens pourrait peut-être du coup nous
expliquer ce qu'est l'économie de la
fonctionnalité est ce que vous en pensez
alors la mise en commun des biens elle
n'est pas nécessairement en tant que tel
garante d'une baisse des émissions je
vais vous donner un exemple idiots qui
est la fille ou si les seuls à pouvoir
se déplacer en avion et et les gens qui
ont un jet privé
il y aurait beaucoup moins de kérosène
consommé dans le monde aujourd'hui
beaucoup moins parce que personne n'aura
les moyens de s'acheter un jet privé
sauf quelques rares milliardaire le fait
d'avoir mis en commun les avions permet
à chaque personne dans cette salle de se
prendre un billet d'avion et du coup la
consommation de l'aérien est beaucoup
plus importante que si on ne pouvait
prendre l'avion qu'avec son propre avion
donc l'économie de la fonctionnalité en
tant que telle n'est pas garante que on
va utiliser moins de ressources
pas grande par contre ce qui peut
marcher c'est si on dit je mets une
réglementation obligeant à consommer
moins de ressources
alors à ce moment il peut apparaître des
partages qui n'existait pas avant
et je vais vous donner un exemple qui
s'appelle la colocation quand on est
suffisamment riche pour s'offrir chacun
son appartement
on a chacun sa salle de bain et sa
douche et puis ici on n'est pas assez
riche et qu'on est en colocation n'y a
qu'une seule salle de bain pour tout le
monde
là on a fait de l'économie de la
fonctionnalité au lieu d'avoir quinze
mètres carrés de salles demain pour soi
on a quinze mètres carrés de salles de
bains pour 3 ou pour catho pour 5 donc
mais ça ça vient d'une contrainte
externe
là en l'occurrence que les gens n'ont
pas désiré qui est l'augmentation du
prix de l'immobilier
donc quand ya une contrainte que
l'économie de la fonctionnalité puisse
permettre de répondre à la contrainte ça
oui par contre dire juste parce qu'à de
l'économie de la fonctionnalité et la
consommation globale va baisser
sanon une petite transition fait un
mauvais jeu non mais c'est pas grave
justement pour mener cette transition
quelle organisation il faut dans nos
territoires
est ce que est ce que est ce qu'il ya
une gouvernance qui permet à la fois que
les gens s'emparent du sujet à la fois
que les bonnes décisions soient prises
est-ce qu'il faut plus de coopération
est ce qu'il faut il faut plus de
compréhension
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya encore
beaucoup d'endroits dans lesquelles les
gens ont du mal à se comprendre et donc
j'en reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure je vraiment les je vais pas
commencer à faire le parisien débarqué
ici qui va vous expliquer comment vous
allez gérer vos affaires
parce que je suis pas sûr de passer la
nuit tranquille si je fais ça par contre
ce dont je suis absolument convaincu
c'est que
on avance bien que quand on se comprend
et le partage de la connaissance c'est
la meilleure manière de encore une fois
je renvoie à l'expérience de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
est très éclairante de ce point de vue
il faut commencer par partage et de la
connaissance
après vous verrez bien ce qui en sortira
et ça va beaucoup dépendre de l'endroit
où on sera mais je pense vraiment que
c'est sale c'est ça la base et alors là
pour le coup les élus doivent donner le
bon exemple
donc s'il ya du partage de l'information
et de la formation ils doivent s'y
coller les premiers vendeurs salut c'est
normal est ce que tu es une autre
question est ce que on va y arriver sans
envisager une décroissance démographique
alors j'ai une échappatoire possible
facile pour cette question qui est que
la décroissance démographique on leur a
de toute façon d'ici à quatre milliards
d'années moment où la planète terre sera
bouffé par le soleil donc la bonne
question est de savoir dans quelles
conditions ça variés
alors si je dis des choses un peu plus
désagréable il est évident que notre
planète fait invariablement treize mille
kilomètres de diamètre au cours du temps
faisait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre ya 5000 ans elle fait treize
mille kilomètres du terme et il ya deux
siècles les 13 8 kilomètres de diamètre
aujourd'hui et dans un siècle sera
toujours 13 8 kilomètres de diamètre
voilà n'en déplaise à monsieur basque
donc plus on est nombreux dessus - il ya
deux morceaux de planètes personne
absolument évident donc qu'il y ait un
petit sujet avec la taille de la
population et après c'est pas une
population mondiale sera pas tellement
de sens après il ya des populations
rapporté à des territoires des endroits
où on peut faire des choses et c est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la planète prise dans son
ensemble peut durablement supporter 8
milliards de personnes voulant vivre
comme une classe moyenne occidentale la
réponse est non du coup qu'est ce qui va
se passer à l'avenir
ben je ne sais pas soit y aura toujours
8 milliards d'individus et le niveau de
consommation va baisser rapidement soit
le niveau de consommation baissera moins
vite et les nombres d'individus baissera
plus vite
alors qu'est ce qui fait baisser les
individus bas il ya deux causes
la maladie et la famine la guerre c'est
pas très rapide la guerre ça favorise
les maladies et les famines ça oui mais
les morts militaires stricto sensu
c'est pas énorme en fait quand vous
regardez bien
le rappeler cet exemple le fameux
inquiets que la grippe espagnole a plus
tu es que la guerre de 14-18 donc et la
peste noire a été le la maladie enfin la
régulation la plus la plus violente de
l'histoire de l'humanité ça a tué la
moitié des gens à ce moment là et ça a
été très étonnamment le début de la
prospérité européenne
la peste noire parce que à l'époque des
énergies renouvelables il y avait plein
de moulins les moulins servait à moudre
la farine et au moment où la peste noire
arrive la moitié de la population
disparaît et donc un moulin sur deux se
retrouvent disponibles pour faire autre
chose que de la farine et qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait à ce moment des soufflet
de forge des marteaux d et c est en fait
la proto industrie a démarré au haut
moyen-âge juste après et ça à préparer
l'avénement de la renaissance
donc en fait le voilà voilà un exemple
peu connus de deux maladies qui a libéré
de l'espace pour ceux qui restaient pour
leur permettre de devenir entre
guillemets plus opulent donc est ce que
on va échapper à une régulation
démographique d'ici à ce que comme
disait qu'ils en soient tous morts non
quelle forme elle prendra quand
commencent à lancer foutent rien est ce
qu'il faut là souhaité je vais pas vous
dire oui je veux dire je ne suis en
faveur ni des génocides ni des pandémies
ni des famines par contre est ce que on
court le risque à ne pas baisser notre
consommation matérielle de ne pas
accroître le risque d'avoir une
régulation non désirées la réponse est
très clairement oui alors une dernière
question si on prend un point de vue
territorial le priver de la sarthe
notamment c'est une toute petite part
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
la france qui elle-même est une petite
part des villes sont de gaz à effet de
serre du monde vous voyez où je veux en
venir
est-ce que ça sert à quoi est-ce que
voilà est-ce que les actions locales
auront une influence sur les émissions
globales alors la réponse est
1 de toute façon il ya motif à agir même
sans ça à cause de ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure sur la diminution des
ressources faut bien voir encore une
fois qu'on a deux des deux facteurs
limitants possible dans notre système
c'est la diminution des ressources ou
l'augmentation des problèmes
environnementaux
mais il ya un problème qui peut arriver
indépendamment des pôles
environnementaux c'est la diminution des
ressources donc se mettre en ordre de
bataille pour des ressources qui de
toute façon vont baisser a du sens quoi
que fassent les autres mieux si les
autres se foutent du problème
ça veut dire qu'ils vont se goberger de
ressources eux aussi donc il y aura
moins pour nous donc en fait plus les
autres s'en foutent
si on prend ça sous l'angle des
ressources et plus il faut qu'on se
dépêche d'agir pour se rendre
indépendant des ressources en question 2
je ne crois pas à la théorie qui
voudrait que quand on fait des choses
dans une direction donnée le reste de
l'humanité y est indifférent vous savez
que le mimétisme est quelque chose qui
est très puissant chez nous et du reste
et même comme ça qu'on élève nos enfants
l'essentiel de l'éducation d'un enfant
consiste à leur faire faire par
imitation ce que nous faisons nous mêmes
limitations c'est à la base de tous les
phénomènes de mode pour est ce que il ya
des modes et des marques etc
tout juste parce qu'on veut limiter les
gens qui ont déjà enfin je veux dire
c'est le mimétisme et qui est à la base
de sa donc l'homme étant un animal
extrêmement profondément animé par le
mimétisme et bien oui et bien l'idée je
ne souscris pas du tout à l'idée que si
on commence à faire des trucs qui
flottent face à la question climatique
tous les autres on doit regarder ans du
lion ou et c'est vachement sympa ton
truc mais je ferai jamais pareil et
l'expérience montre que c'est pas ça qui
se passe donc le le le
l'idée que un territoire pourrait faire
des choses pertinentes et n'avoir jamais
nulle part aucun suiveurs dans le monde
j'y crois pas par contre si les choses
sont pas pertinentes
les autres ailleurs auront beau jeu de
se gratter la tête en disant est ce
qu'il faut faire la même chose mais ici
c'est pertinent
il y aura des suiveurs si je prends à
l'échelle des pays
le la france a déjà fait un certain
nombre de choses tout seul dans son coin
qui ensuite sont devenues universelles
par exemple le système métrique par
exemple la tva l'impôt
bref et il n'y a pas très longtemps le
bilan carbone c'est à dire aujourd'hui
la norme mondiale sur la manière de
faire une empreinte carbone d'une
organisation celle de la france tu es
venu de votre serviteur qui un jour a
été tout seul donc l'idée qu'on fasse
des trucs d'abord dans son coin et
qu'ensuite ça diffuse en fait c'est la
norme
c'est toujours comme ça que ça se passe
donc agissons donc il faut agir sans se
gratter la tête
merci infiniment monsieur jancovici
je vous propose de terminer cette soirée
je veux laisser le président de dire
petit mot de l'afflux d'enfants à
désinfecter
rester avec moi ces gens qui ont essayé
de rester avec eux il va ben oui quand
même
pour le moment de la conclusion un mot
de la conclusion très très rapide
d'abord vous remercier bien sûr de votre
intervention
et puis à plusieurs fois plusieurs
reprises vous avez été mauvaise nouvelle
mauvaise nouvelle on nous avait dit ce
soir mais j'ai envie de dire aussi bonne
nouvelle bonne nouvelle puisqu'on a un
territoire qui s'engagent eux vous
l'avez compris sur un plan alimentaire
territoriale sur la rénovation
énergétique sur les ce que vous nous
disiez ce que pouvait faire des
collectivités donc je crois que on est
sur la bonne voie on agit et puis
l'autre chose que je retiens c'est que
le premier escalier de la première
marche de l'escalier c'est la
sensibilisation et c'est je crois ce que
ce qu'on nous en fait ce soir est donc
on est on est en bonne voie il ya aussi
des choses positives
voilà ce que je voulais terminer cette
cette conférence et puis on voulait vous
remercier aussi avec des produits et
produits locaux on a fait on n'a pas
fait un panier gourmand on a fait un sac
un sac gourmande une vallée de la sarthe
alors pour les spectateurs oui c'est
lourd donc on avait dû jasnières si vous
n'avez pas eu le temps de le goûter tout
à l'heure donc on espère pouvoir le
faire et puis plein de produits locaux
qui est qu'ils sont produits sur sur le
territoire de la vallée de la sarthe des
rillettes
bien sûr nous sommes derrière et puis
aussi nous sommes à sable et donc le
petit sablé que vous avez la faucille
plus du miel plein de bonnes choses qui
vous rappelleront votre passage dans
notre dans nos territoires et puis
n'hésitez pas de vous y arrêter parce
que passer c'est bien mais vous y
arrêter c'est bien vous êtes à l'arrêt
merci à vous bonne fin de soirée
[Applaudissements]